I shocking opinion. I think that's a bad thing to do, isn't it?
That seems like a bad thing to do. >> I I don't often get
angry and I don't often get researchy and I don't often start
pulling things, but when I do, when I am activated, I have in
the I have been up for like 60, 70, 80 hours. >> Hello,
this is Dickers. >> Is that your British accent? Is that
what we're doing? >> Not on dickers. We just talked right
now. Right.
I bet you you think that there's no proof that Destiny's minor,
right? That's proven. There's more proof of that than the idea
that the US went to the moon. Okay, >> guys. It's cool.
Listen, we'll we'll site Listen, even if Destiny is a like it
it's worth it. It's worth it to see Queen unhappy. These people
are brain
>> Let me Let me take a look.
Someone linked it. Who linked it? You linked it in stream chat
just a second ago. Do I have it here? There it is. When people
accuse me of having political position positions that are just
the opposite of my enemies, they are projecting their own approach
to politics.
They are projecting their own approach to politics. Uh
would you give So this is the question here. Okay. Would you
give permission to the creators involved in the incubator program
to share their contracts? Would Chorus be willing to share the
contracts publicly? That would solve everything. So either side
of this, right? Either side of this, if you're willing to show
the contracts, that actually solves all of the things that are
dangling right now. all the things that are like unproven, that
solves all of them. This is a position basically every sane person
I've seen look at this drama, uh, look at this like I guess scandal,
whatever you want to call it, agrees with this. If we could just
see the contracts,
we'd be totally fine, right? I don't understand. How is this
a spitebased position? Where's the spite? Who am I spiteful of?
By the way, the only thing we've seen from the contracts seems
to totally back up the piece and the part that it alleges, right?
That's the collaboration part that the the piece of the contract
we've seen backs the piece up entirely.
And everybody who says that this is trusting Taylor Loren's,
you have to be brain damaged to think this is about trusting
Taylor Loren in any way. It is not.
All this is about is trusting Wired's editing editorial staff
to go and vet factual claims and make sure that they're not going
to be on the on the hook for lying about chorus. When you look
at the piece, it says Wired has looked into this, right? Uh HK97,
yes, this is of course the classic response. Okay. When people
accuse me of having political positions that are just the opposite
of my enemies, they're projecting their own approach onto politics.
And if we uh look at the uh Very interesting, why why does he
have the Palestinian flag and the Keia again? Why did he Why
has he been doing this? The Low Bro really tweeted that out while
repping a Palestinian flag in a Keia. Guys, they're just projecting
on to me. She's
are not paying you know what's bad for the movement.
You know what's really bad for the movement?
Throwing away all of your principles and not caring about the
truth just so you can get a dunk on somebody you dislike. That's
what's not good for the movement. Okay. Uh this is another fantastic
comment. It's just me to you. When you view everything through
the Destiny versus Hassan lens, you're just spiteful. You're
spiteful against Destiny. I guess so. Like if technically my
opinion is not Desty's opinion then it is just spiteful towards
him. I suppose I suppose who did that? Uh everybody who propagated
the lie that she took money from the 1630 fund.
Every single person who propagated that lie which is a bunch
of influencers including Hutch, right? Every single person who
propagated that is throwing away their principles, not caring
about the truth, and just slandering this person because they're
upset they wrote an article they don't like. Yes, I'm I'm against
that. I think that's bad. I shocking opinion. I think that's
a bad thing to do, isn't it? That seems like a bad thing to do.
Who did you block? Uh, some DG. I have no idea. I've got most
of these people blocked. Destiny's quote tweeting them. They're
probably just somebody posting that community. Oh, they're also
Yeah, they're all calling the article debunked when the article
has no retractions on it. There are no retractions on this article.
And let me grab Let me grab Hutch's opinion here. What was Hutch's
thing? Oh, Hutch Hutch comes out with this. Hold on. This is
uh this is Hutch's thumbnail.
Debunked.
Debunked. Deunked. We've debunked it.
Nothing here's been debunked. If you think this article has been
debunked, you've been lied to. You actually have been lied to.
You don't know what you're talking about. The factual There are
zero retractions on this article. There are zero retractions.
Wired is a reputable publisher. If it's been debunked, how are
there no retractions on the article? Make it make sense. The
title is correct. It's wildly misleading. The the title by line
and first paragraph of the article are not perfect. Uh they are
I would say they're misleading primarily because I believe it
would be illegal for chorus to directly tell these people what
to produce for content. So I would agree that it's illegal there,
but I don't think that assertion has even effectively been debunked.
I think they shouldn't make it because I haven't seen the positive
proof in their direction to make that assertion. Okay. But I
don't I think the idea that it's been debunked is also false.
Uh the the idea I've seen debunking this. Okay. The debunking
of this to me has been okay. It's uh it's okay. Here's a here's
a creator who's in chorus who's pro Palestine and has called
out the government, the Israeli government. Look, they're not
just towing the party line. Okay, that's like one or two influencers
out of everybody in this cohort, right? That's one or two out
of everybody in the cohort. You could still easily be doing this
and have those one or two so you could just make that point.
I don't think that's really But by the way, I just I think it's
wrong for Taylor Loren to assert that anyway.
In my opinion, it's wrong for Taylor Loren to assert that. And
that is the one thing that I would like to see corrected or changed
in the article is to say that when they're being paid $8,000
up to $8,000 a month to push the party line. No, no, no, no,
no. being paid $8,000 a month to
receive like messaging talking points each day, like each weekday,
and you you could get into something more direct. Okay. I think
you you'd have to do something like that, but I do not believe
they're legally allowed to provide talking points to these people.
I don't think so. Hired sucked. It's owned by the same company
that owns Reddit. This is such a Why do you make such stupid
statements? Only people mute. I don't understand why you What
is that? That doesn't You can't tell me
only mute sucks. He likes
some other thing that's totally unrelated.
I That That tells me nothing. That's not even based on information.
You're just You're just trying to tie their reputation into another
entity. It's stupid. He looked at Destiny's tweet thread on Taylor
receiving dark money. Understandable if not, but I'd be interested
if you agree or not since he's the only one I've seen link actual
sources. I've seen lots of people link the actual sources. How
does he how does he refute that the Omidar fund has come out
and said that there there are uh what is it journalist and residence
program is not related to any funding they receive from any other
uh place. The Omidier fund has come out and said that that is
not the case that they do not take money from the 1630 fund for
that program. I don't know how you I don't know how you could
say that it's a valid thing to say when it's pretty objective
that they've come out and said no no this is not happening. You
have a response to that black cap. Go ahead link Destiny's thread.
I'll go through it. happy to go through it. Uh, also the donation
they point to was years before she got there. No. Uh, it might
be might be years before she got there. She says it's a refund
that it's on the books as a refund. I did. It didn't seem that
way to me. Okay. When I looked at that donation, the the place
it is in the books, I didn't go through their books comprehensively,
but it didn't seem to be a refund. But if it's like way before
she got there, then yeah, I don't see how that would be relevant.
The more accurate talking point if you're not a okay if you're
not a total [__] what you say here is I think that
the 1630 fund gets money from Pierre Omidar and Torren gets money
from Pierre omittar now the problem is the 1630 fund gets that
money without having to report it and they don't say how much
they they're just disclosing that Pierro Midiar is a funer right
so you can say that Pierro Midiar funds both but in one case
he funds it transparently with a foundation named after him.
In the other case, he provides money to the 1630 Foundation without
any actual tracing and any actual way to track it. Uh let's see.
So, you're linking this. Let's take a look. Let's take a look.
Uh by the way, still doesn't mean any of the articles debunked,
right? But let's take a look and see if Taylor is really uh taking
money from this place, from the 1630 fund, which is the allegation.
Okay. the allegation that I don't like. That is just a a pure
transparent
slandering.
Let's pull this up. Let's take a look. Okay, correct me if I'm
wrong. I'm not knowledgeable in these types of tax entities,
but it seems like this is just a clever word game that Pier at
Pierre or the Amidar group is playing here to claim that they
haven't used money received by the 1630 fund when they essentially
have. No, here we go. Dark spooky dark money time. Well, we'll
see. Many are claims to operate as a hybrid structure and LLC
and 501c3.
Uh, so they're LLC 501c3.
Okay. 501c3. Uh, hybrid structure. Oh, 501c3. 50
1 C3 is the nonprofit disclo uh distinction, right? 501c3.
Standard nonprofit. Yep. Yep. Standard nonprofit. Okay. So, we'll
say that because the 1630 fund is a 501c4,
they must disclose on a public form 990 who they give grants
to. In 20122, they gave a grant to the Omidar Network Services
LLC of $45,000.
Oh, this is what it seemed like to me too that like it wasn't
a refund, right? It seemed like this to me. So, before she was
there, since the Omidia Since Omidia Network Services LLC is
just an LLC with no 501 status, we have no public filings available
to gain any transparency into this entity. Dark money. Okay,
fair enough. Uh, however, since Omidar Network Fund, Inc. is
a 501c3, we do see who donated money to them in 2022. On their
form 990PF,
at the bottom of the form, we see the sub uh subsidiary of the
Omidar Network LLC, Omidar Network Services LLC provided 15,000
or sorry 50,400,000 of inkind services to the 501c3 part of the
hybrid entity. So, is this to their own part of the hybrid entity?
Uh, the amount contributed is 15 million. So that to themselves
they provided. So this is just a limited liability corporation.
So the LLC provides 15 million in services to the Omidrar network
fund. Okay. Conclusion. Yes. The 1630 fund has donated money
at least in 2022 to the umar network by donating money to the
Omidar network services LLC which collaborates with the
part of itself.
Okay. So, this is saying $45,000,
right, is the contribution if I'm not mistaken, right? In 2022,
before Taylor was in this program, right? So, what has been proven
here that at one point in the past, the Omidar Network Services
LLC received a $45,000 grant. Again, I I thought this seemed
like a a cash grant. Taylor says that it's a return, basically
like a refund.
I don't know. I don't know the actual underlying facts of this,
right? But even if in 2022 they took that grant, right, they
wouldn't be a company that for Taylor Loren, like Taylor Loren
is not accepting money from the 1630 fund, right? I don't see
how that's proven out at all. And if you listen closely to the
people who are informed, who who actually care about being informed
on any of these issues, the accusation is not even that Taylor
or her or the Amidar Network are taking money from the 1630 fund.
The accusation is that Pierro Midiar is the person donating to
both of these things. That's the actual intelligent allegation,
which also provides no hypocrisy point. There is no hypocrisy
point there. It's a totally pointless thing to point out. We're
going to cover the John Fabro tweet as well. So, hold on. Let's
see here. Receives no funding for the reporters and residents
program via the 1630 fund or any other outside sources. So this
is a uh so this is a separate fund right that exists via their
own funding mechanisms that does they don't they're explicitly
saying they don't slush money around between these things right
so I don't see how this remotely proves anything
this is just slop that's being slopped onto your plate it's not
proof of anything about Taylor Loren's taking dark money right
there's nothing here about that at all so that's fantastic I
don't know what this is supposed to be a response to if Omidar
is lying why is this on Taylor Lauren ends. That's a great question,
too. But I don't think this is even asserting that Amidar is
lying. It's just a straight up lie. It's just straight up slop,
right? Like, this is just this is pointing out facts that don't
actually disprove anything Taylor's saying. Oh, sorry. Maybe
she went a little too far. Neither I nor they have ever received
funding. I don't think that's what they say. She's uh she's going
out of her way to strengthen the claim. Now, I think she's what?
She's just, I guess, reacting to being smeared. They may have
taken 45 uh part of their corporation, the LLC that provides
services back to them, might have taken funding in 2022, but
they do not receive funding for the program that Taylor Loren
is in. And that is what we're talking about. Right. Anyway, so
I don't see what this is supposed to prove. It doesn't seem to
prove anything. Right now, what I would be interested in is if
there is some way to prove that the 45,000 provided back to Omidar
was a refund of some kind for services that were supposed to
be provided or paid for by the Omdia Network Services LLC because
that's what Taylor Loren claims and I have no idea if that's
true or not. Pisco said earlier today that he handled that conversation
poorly. He was tired and too irritable.
He spar sparked a bit too much up in the bowl there. Okay, that's
what happened. That's what happened in that combo. All right.
We love Pisco, though. We love Pisco. We love Pisco. Okay. So,
I I don't see how this is Correct me if I'm wrong. I just don't
see how this is actually relevant to whether or not Taylor Loren
has taken money from a dark money source essentially. Yeah. I
don't I don't get it. But if anyone if anyone disagrees, you're
welcome to point to me or point out to me where you actually
disagree. Let's keep looking. Let's keep taking a look. Okay,
we had Drew. We had Oh, the the Destiny thing. Yeah, the spite
thing is just funny to me. It's very funny to me. Okay, I I just
want to cover this tweet real quick. I don't even know what the
I mean, of course he's siding with Taylor Lorenz and Hassan.
It's so boring, so predictable.
I don't think I side with Taylor Lorenz and Hassan here at all.
I've I've given the take multiple times, right? Uh I don't actually
think dark money is like automatically evil. I think having a
middleman for that dark money that you trust the principles of
that that basically is telling you, okay, we're getting this
money from an unconfirmed source, but we're not beholden to this
money. Okay, if that's the way it's got to work, at least find
somebody you trust who's going to manage that money, right? Find
somebody you trust and and work with them, right?
Hey, we we need this. You know, it's a nuclear arms race and
this is the hydrogen bomb. Yes, that's uh that's that's the argument
and I'm fine with that argument. Just get rid of the contract
provisions you say don't represent your entire organization,
right? Get rid of those contract provisions and you're golden.
Disclose. Disclose. Disclose.
Wait, you joined the reporters and residence program in July
of 2025? Yes. Porter Beller. Yes. That that that entire thread
Destiny did is just slop for like I would love to see if somebody
else has like basically reposted this as if it's intelligent.
Is there anybody here that's smart that we would think is smart?
I just want to get it proven to myself that they're not intelligent.
Oh, shocking. The person who linked the thread. Shocking. Shocking.
Very shocking.
No, there is no intelligent person retweeting this. Okay, we're
good. We're good. All right. Nobody else thought this cooked
at all. Thank god. Thank god. Faith in humanity slightly restored.
All right. What else we got here? We going to go to the Z the
Z posts.
Dude, the the hypocrisy angles on this are so broken and stupid,
right? Like nobody is just coming at this directly, which is
so weird to me. Have you considered that he's saving democracy?
Nobody here is saving democracy. These people are all just fighting
for influence and telling you, trying to moralize it to you so
you think they're good. Okay, that's all that's happening here.
Okay. Our three Oh, sorry. This is uh Z posted this. Okay. I
find it funny that Hassan the Hunt is criticizing people who
are part of Chorus, yet he worked for the Young Turks, which
accepted money from 3L Capital, Greycraft, Eve Ventures, and
Windco that. Okay, so the the for-profit entity, the Young Turks,
accepted grant money from for-profit entities, I assume in exchange
for stakes in the Young Turks, right? How is that even remotely
similar to what's happening here? People are trying to trying
to compare it to seed funding. Seed funding is the the profit
incentive is there. The profit incentive is an understandable
motive, right? How do we compare this? It's not compare. It's
like totally it's totally incomparable.
Also, didn't I think Z worked here at the same time, didn't she?
Does the Young Turks make a profit? It's a for-profit entity.
I don't know if they actually turn a profit, but it is a for-profit
entity. The term forprofit does not mean you make a profit. I
could make a terrible company. I could make a terrible organization.
I could make it like an LLC. I could declare it's for profit
and then I could totally fail and that would still be a for-profit
venture. Okay. Jen had some wild takes on the Yemen thing today.
Interesting. All right. Well, I think that's uh that's it for
that stuff. We're finally ready to get into some of the takes
on this. Okay, let's see. Z gave a video. She posted a video
today trying to say what her opinions are.
>> let's see. The NFL is a nonprofit.
Sure. I'm not I'm not even arguing about nonprofits uh not being
shady in some way or that they can't be used for profit in some
way. Jacob, I'm just saying that like for-profit ventures being
funded by for-profit venture capitalists is like America. That's
like the the it's a story as old as time as far as America goes.
Okay, that's just that is literally just America. But Z had a
had a post. The hypocrisy of these influencers is wild. Apparent
way in this chorus drama, but not for the same reason that everybody
else is because for those of you guys who didn't see yesterday,
Wired came out with an article that talks about a bunch of left-leaning
creators that were a part of this dark money organization. I
just find it to be so hypocritical that so many of the names
on this list at the same time that they were working for this
organization were saying that I was money laundering without
any evidence and that I was taking advantage of creators. And
I know that a lot of people on the internet
>> Wait, what the organization? I just find it to be so
hypocritical that so many of the names on this list at the same
time that they were working for this
>> Wait, is she hold on? Wait, is Z based? Z's calling
out the hypocrisy of the influencers themselves.
That might actually hold water. That might that could actually
hold water here. Yes, >> we're saying that I was money
laundering without any evidence and that I was taking advantage
of creators. And I know that a lot of people on the internet
right now are really upset that people were taking money to do
this work. And I don't really have a problem with that. I don't
think that creators should not make money doing what they do.
It's a Listen, I'm of the controversial opinion
that I think it's okay for creators on the internet to make money.
I know that that's I don't know why these lefties like Hassan
Why does Hassan hold the position that creators online shouldn't
make money, guys? Why does Taylor Loren think that creators online
shouldn't make money? Why do all these Why are they arguing that
creators online shouldn't make money? I'm I'm of the humble opinion
that creators online should make some money, guys. Okay, I that's
a fantastic straw man you built up here. Okay, that's amazing.
Nobody's making that argument. That's one of one of like three
or four really dumb arguments I hear all the time. Guys, isn't
it crazy how these people think creators shouldn't be able to
make money? I personally believe that creators should be able
to make money. A job and they deserve to get paid for it. My
first issue with this is controlling creators. I just don't think
that it is good for our democracy to be making people sign contracts
where they can't go against a certain elected official or they
can't say what they believe politically. And if you follow me,
you know that I talk about this all the time that the Democrats
need a strong media
>> Is she saying that's happening here? It's a very weird
opening cuz I thought she was defending in some of the other
places, but maybe she's not defending. And the Republicans have
just completely overtaken us in this way to the point where their
media infrastructure is so powerful that they are using that
media infrastructure to help them win elections. But the reason
why the Republican media infrastructure is so strong is because
it's Mary is because they never criticize anybody on their side
no matter how vile the moral transgression. That's the most important
story here, guys. you have to let me do whatever I want or else
Trump stays in office for a third term. If you criticize anyone
involved here, okay, you're you're putting Trump in office again.
All right, that's just the that's the way it is. She's probably
not going to say that. Okay, she's probably not going to say
that. >> But the reason why the Republican media infrastructure
is so strong is because it's married to an aggressive ground
game. And that is what the DNC and this group and many other
groups that have failed in the past have not been able to successfully
do. I think that there's this idea.
I missed it. I missed it. I missed it. The solution to their
failings is me. Oh, I didn't I didn't respect her game. Okay.
I didn't respect her game.
The solution to this is the thing I'm good >> Idea out
there that if we just control all the influencers that somehow
someway that will help us win elections, but it won't. And that's
why I believe that the UN America Tour National ground game which
is shown by our numbers of support are so strong. And yes, we
have a long way to go. But the reason why I believe that we've
gotten off the ground so strong is because we've selected creators
that actually want to change this country electorally. Our fall
tour is just about to start. And if you want to support our work,
please go to our website, sign up to volunteer, sign up to donate.
And as always, if you have questions after watching this video,
send me a DM and I will help you out. Wow,
it is an advertisement. That's a very interesting video. No one
can even put your tour's name in their title.
Uh your ad uh
your SEO. Okay. Un your SEO first and then we can un America.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. I'm here for the Hassan raid.
I've heard this. Okay. Hassan will be raiding us today, guys.
I know it. I know it. I've only been streaming on Twitch for
a Hassan raid. Okay. Hey, Hassan is going to raid us today while
he's out of the country. Let's go. W Hassan, get that raid in
here, Hassan. I know you want to. I know you want to, Hassan.
Get it done. All right, that's the the Z stuff. Okay, I think
the first thing I'm going to do here today is we're going to
watch first video. Okay, first video we're going to watch here.
This is the Taylor Loren's interview with Glenn Greenwald. Now,
this will be interesting because I think this will be Taylor
speaking on this without the wired editorial staff to hold her
hand. And it'll be interesting to see her actual mindset on this.
Okay. It'll just be interesting to see the mindset because only
on Rumble. That was a lie. Oh, it might only be on Rumble. Hold
on. I got a Rumble link to this and it's possible that this would
get cut off. Or maybe they do a Rumble only section or something.
Give me a second. Here's the Rumble video. No, it seems like
it's about the same. Or maybe not. Maybe not. Maybe not. What
do we got? Third. Yeah, it's a little longer on Rumble. Let's
We'll watch it. We'll watch it here first. Okay. This is the
guy seen in a thong, right? No. No. That was that was not Glenn.
Okay. That was AI. Taylor Rens is an American journalist who
reports on internet culture mainly through her Substack Right
Now, User Magazine. Although she writes for many other media
outlets. She also does reporting on her YouTube channel uh titled
Tell Orens. She has previously been a staff reporter for the
Washington Post and the New York Times and has written and >> I
I don't know how people could possibly think this is a thing
that could happen. I actually don't
um I I understand why like people joke about it, right? I understand
why people uh DJ cheaters would joke about it, but like none
of my political positions overlap with the son basically at all.
I don't understand why anybody like actually believes that if
you've ever watched Yeah. Okay. Forgotten Jones, I got you. reported
for numerous media outlets. She has a new exclusive story that
she reported in Wired magazine today entitled, quote, "A dark
money group is secretly funding high-profile Democratic influencers.
We want to talk to her in depth about that as well as the work
she's been doing in warning of and reporting on the dangers to
free speech by new online censorship provisions such as UK's
online safety act and particularly the growing movement to under
the guise of age verification and protecting children requiring
your identity be submitted before allowing you to participate
in multiple platforms on the internet. Taylor, it is great to
see you. Really appreciate you taking the time to talk to us
tonight. Glenn, I'm surprised you would say it's great to see
me. >> It is great to see you. Um, you know, I have had
that experience many time where you have arguments based on differences
uh with somebody. These two, by the way, a year ago, hated each
other. I forget what they fought over, but they had a massive
blowout like a year ago and
and it's interesting. It's funny that they're back together.
They're they're here in the end. Okay. They're back. They're
friends again.
So I am glad to see you. Thank you for coming on. >> Yeah,
I wish you had given me this benefit of the doubt uh years ago
because I've been covering these issues >> Try not to be
too spiteful, Taylor. Try not to be too spiteful. You got a guy
out here who's taking your side. Could you just be grace? Could
you just be gracious? A little grace. Never kiss anybody, Taylor.
Come on. >> Years. No, I know for years. >> I know.
And I maybe I could say the same. You have your own show you
could have invited me on as well. But any event, we'll get to
some of that. I think you're >> welcome anytime.
>> This is uh incredibly petty from both. Well, more from
Taylor's side. She started it, but now Glenn's Glenn's like,
"Oh, you
was just I was just trying to extend an olive branch and you
spit my face and now Glenn's just like recovering. >> I'm
glad.
I'll definitely invite myself on. since you're here. Um, and
I do want to get into a couple of those, uh, kind of past
differences in a very civil way, but only as they relate to things
we want to talk to you about tonight. Um, so you have this article
in Wired, and it basically narrates how this dark money group
is paying
Democratic Party influencers, influencers, content creators,
podcasters who generally support the Democratic Party money in
secret, meaning requiring them
Look at Glenn. Glenn's a sneaky guy. He's saving Taylor right
off the bat. Glenn isn't running with the title or the by line.
He's actually reading the article and saying what he believes
to actually be the case. Right?
So, he's not even going to let Taylor run away with this. Get
a little hyperbolic. He immediately sets, oh, you're basically
they're paying people who are largely in line with the Democratic
party, which is far more accurate, far less misleading >> to
keep it secret. explain what this group is, kind of who funds
it and and how it's functioning. >> Yeah, so the 1630 fund
is this massive powerful liberal dark money group that sprung
up in the wake of Citizens United and um this is when dark money
really started to like become a big thing in politics really.
I mean, I think Citizens United was >> Okay, so just to
be clear, when we talk about dark money here, this is obviously
going to be talking about dark money sources. Okay, sources of
dark money. No, no, no, no. When you're talking about Citizens
United, it's just obviously it's obvious what you're talking
about, right? Money that you can't verify the source of, that
you can't verify the amounts of. Yeah, it's it's literally talking
about the effect of the Citizens United ruling.
It's not confusing. It's not just a garbage buzz word. It's very
clear what they mean, right? Or it's very clear what Taylor means
in this case. I've seen people say that. I've seen people like
draw attention to the word dark money and then they go, I don't
even know what she means when in the context of talking about
Citizens United. It is not even a little bit confusing what she
means. And it's disingenuous to suggest otherwise. >> 2009,
but it was really in the 2010s that these groups started to emerge
and start doing a funding. Now, they're mostly on the right.
A lot of dark money is on the right, but this specific dark money
group uh funds liberal causes. So they raised I think something
like 400 million they distributed in uh according to Politico
in 2022 I think it was they do a lot of work in the space and
what they're doing recently which I encou >> by the way
just I'm going to say it again because I think some people need
to hear it kind of like Assad is bad okay I think some people
need a little thing here I am not of the position that dark money
is just just uh at a base level immoral I don't believe that
okay I think you can take dark money and have it be like totally
fine Okay. I don't think it's just automatically bad. I'm not
arguing all like all downstream effects of Citizens United are
bad. I'm not doing any of that. All right. Just so we're clear.
I'm not I'm not going to argue that here. So, if anybody thinks
that that's my position, I'm just making it clear now. That's
not my position.
>> Covered in my story is that they're running this influencer
program. There's been all of this talk since the Democrats lost
so spectacularly um last fall about finding like the liberal
Joe Rogan. They they're they discovered the internet exists and
now they're trying to figure out what to do with it. And um this
is the strategy that they've come up with is essentially funneling
this dark money to influencers through Chorus, which is this
content creator, you know, in liberal content creator kind of
network. >> You know, one of one of the things that I don't
understand about and I never have understood about and it is
true. It's like Democrats had no interest in going on these massive
podcasts during the 2024 election or even before in anyone paying
attention to the internet
understood the massive audience and reach that these podcasts
had. I mean much larger than the cable shows that the or face
the nation or meet the press that these Democratic office holders
would love to go grow on. It was kind of this massive thing growing
under the nose a lot of people in media who just don't pay attention
to anything new. And I know you've been reporting on on on this
kind of internet culture for a long time, but it strikes me that
the way these shows that they're so worried about like Joe Rogan,
like Theo Vaughn, Andrew Schultz, a lot of these these kind of
biggest uh programs that became proTrump influencers,
they really emerged organically. They It's not like they had
dark money funding them. where people who went online, you know,
started having just like
>> uh Wow. Wow.
Glenn Glenn somehow
hits the nail on the head right off the bat. Yeah. A lot of the
people, the big guys that they're concerned about, that's not
dark money. That's people with passion who built their platforms
organically. And the question should be, how did you turn those
people away from you and onto the other side? normal conversations,
often comedians. And in the course of that, they started attracting,
you kind of call them the normies who weren't that interested
in politics. And then they became political to the extent it
related to their specific concerns, things like censorship or
woke suppression, things that they perceived were harming them.
Democrats think that they're going to compete with that by taking
either people who are already having an audience full of liberal
and Democrats and just shuffling money to them or trying to create
it in some artificial way where they're kind of forced to just
do political content. Like what do they think is their goal here?
>> Yeah. Well, I want to be clear, there is tons of money
on the right in terms of dark money. The the the the Republican
ecosystem is flush with dark money. Um, but the difference is
that it's more bottom up in terms of their media strategy than
top down. So, you're right, especially the comedians that you
mentioned. I've never heard of those people taking dark. >> Okay.
I I'm just going to make it clear now. I've never heard Taylor
Loren talk on this topic. Okay. So, she seems to know my talking
points and why I think this idea of like the the top down control
is like stupid, but I did not get this from her. This is just
my opinion on watching this media ecosystem grow over time. So,
I don't know why she I don't know why she has the correct opinion
that maps onto mine. Very shocking. First time I'm hearing it.
>> Money at all. But there are a lot of conservative influencers,
Benny Johnson, Tim P, others that have taken dark money or have
taken money where they don't exactly know 100% where it's coming
from, who you know who the funer is. Um, and that's not great.
But usually the way it works and what I've seen from my reporting
is that these Republican groups will sort of notice someone online.
They might not even have interaction with that. Who is the top?
The DNC or what? Uh, no. I would say the top would be, you know,
billionaire donors to things like the 1630 fund who want to push
Democrat politics, right? Who want to get their their candidates
elected and want to build systems that help enable that. I would
say that's the top here,
right? But they they like having control. That's just how the
Democrat works right now. They like having control. They're not
willing to Well, at least from what I've seen, I've seen no appetite
to support people who really are like even I would say like 50%
against you, right? They'll support people who are like 5% against
them, but I've seen no appetite to support people who are like
50/50, which on the Republican side, I see a lot of that. Like
there were a lot of people who were 50/50 toss-ups, like Joe
Rogan, right? That that he's now supported Trump, but that he
was a total toss-up guy. You could have easily had that guy on
your side. Okay. I don't I don't see think I've seen any appetite
to do that yet. And we'll see if it gets there. Maybe it gets
there. >> Online. And they'll just sort of start pumping.
They'll start boosting them in the feed. They'll start doing
paid media for them. Like just sort of organically like testing
things and boosting things and trying a lot. The Democrats are
obsessed with control. We know that they love this like top-down
sort of structure of media because they're such institutionalists.
And so with the influencer industry, not only did they sort of
malign the influencer industry for years, but now they're sort
of seeking to gatekeep it in various ways and um and sort of
like, you know, have this more top- down control over it, not
some sort of organic thing. And I think it's very notable, too,
that the content creators that they want to fund don't have any
organic traction. Most of them are just these sort of centrist
uh neoliberal, you know, people. >> I don't know about
that at all. I don't I've seen no evidence of this. I don't think
this is necessarily true. >> People that frankly will never
call, you know, a genocide a genocide. They'll never speak out
against Israel. They'll
this is See, she's going off the edge. She's going off the edge
into Oh, come on, Taylor. Come on, Taylor. Don't be >> Never
speak out against um you know, all of the censorship stuff. They're
not rocking the boat. Basically, they're happy to tow the Democratic
party line. And I think that's a problem because those are not
the people that have cultural currency online. If the
>> One second, I got to answer Missy Elliot because they
had an awesome tweet about this. Hi, Jacock. Have you seen any
of Pisco's coverage on the chorus stuff? I'm curious your thoughts.
Um, I think Pisco reflexively wanted to hardcore defend all of
this. I think he absolutely wanted his his initial reaction was
to defend as hard as he possibly could. I found that a little
weird to be honest with you. Um,
I didn't think some of his arguments were the worst. I think
probably what it's going to come down to in my opinion is seeing
the contracts and I I think it's going to I realistically feel
like the uh I feel like his position is not terribly far from
mine. He just is pushing against Aaron. Aaron is the person he
was arguing against when he initially came up with this like
right when he started setting his positions. And so that's going
to push him like I don't know to a pretty Aaron's really good
at arguing too. So I she pushed him in that argument. It was
very funny. But I have to pull up the the Missy Elliott tweet
here. Okay. because this was just really funny. Aaron straight
away being an aggressive rude [__] interrupted Pisco
Litty and wouldn't even let him finish. We got to watch this.
>> I'm not saying that they need to be maximally transparent
to the point that you disclose. I partnered with Quest to promote
this product to sponsor it. I was paid for it and also here are
the talking points that they gave me. It's understood that the
advertisement read or the way that they present it was likely
formulated in conjunction with a marketing team that gave them.
>> Uh Missy, I was watching this um I was watching this
with Cherry while it was happening live. Okay.
And like we both died laughing at this point. Just get ready
for this crazy interruption from straight ra >> guidance
on how to present it that gave them talking points just by disclosing
in partnership with Crest sponsored by Crest # ad. All of those
things can be intimated and it's trivially obvious that you likely
as somebody who is who who sponsored a product did not come up
with all of those. >> So there's a pisco interruption.
That's not the one. Hold on. >> Those materials. >> No,
no. I I think you should disclose the financial relationship.
I think you should disclose the the um organizational Let me
finish this. What I'm saying the organizational >> I am
not interrupting you.
>> Does she Does she do something with her face or does
she like lean towards the >> No. No. I I think you should
disclose the financial relationship. I think you should disclose
the the um organizational. Let me finish this. What I'm saying,
the organizational.
She doesn't She's literally stonefaced the whole time. She doesn't
even give like a visual indication. She's trying to cut it at
all. She's like sitting back, arms at her side. Dude, let me
finish this point. >> Financial relationship. I think you
should disclose the the um organizational Let me finish this
point. I'm saying the organizational
>> I'm not interrupting you. I don't need to I don't think
that you need to >> The funny thing is is Pisco started
trying to cut in while she was still talking and she kept talking,
right? She kept talking over him. So that's not But that was
him trying to interrupt and then she basically stops and then
he he goes and then he's like, "Don't don't interrupt me." It
it is funny. I'm sorry. It's just like that is incredibly funny.
Yes, Cherry. Like I It is so funny. And then straight raid found
this uh this Pokemon card. Okay, this Pisco Pokemon card right
here.
Pisco 60 HP. Future sight preemptively cuts off a female opponent's
imagined interruption that only existed in his head. Damage doubles
if she wasn't even talking. >> Listen,
at this point I would believe if Pisco can like read her mind
because I would buy it if he says, "Nope, she was talking on
me in her head." And so he just like you have like shut up even
in your head. Shut up. >> He was just real for that. >> Fair
enough.
H. Sorry. I It was just such a funny clip. Okay. Please don't
interrupt me. And that's not By the way, this is not like a serious
indictment of Pisco. It's just a very funny moment. Okay. It's
just We're all having fun. We're all having fun. Imagine if she
did start to say something though. How funny would that be? Oh,
if she was like leaning in. Yeah, maybe. Uh, tell tell Cherry,
not the woman, Cherry, to get close to the mic if she wants to
talk. I just need to get a second mic set up. That's that's what
I need to do. Okay.
Get a second mic set up so that I can actually have Cherry without
having to come up. She's got to come over to my desk and like
lean right into the mic. Yell from Okay. Okay, dude. It's hard
to yell from the basement. All right, let's get back to Taylor.
She was just about to introduce the Zog talking point, which
I've explicitly said this is stupid. Don't bring up the Zog thing.
Don't Don't try to make this about Zog in some way. Okay, these
people have no sense of self-preservation.
Dude, these people would be soed in the media environment from
like four years ago. They would all be getting deplatformed for
the amount they just go to like the Israel will be nowhere near
an issue and they'll just drag Israel into it. They would have
gotten so four years ago, okay? They would have gotten destroyed
for this.
Now, okay, now with Israel engaging in the war in Gaza, you get
a little more excuse. There's a lot more leeway. But I'm telling
you, you guys don't even know what it was like. you know, people
that frankly will never call, you know, a genocide a genocide.
They'll never speak out against Israel. They'll never speak out
against um, you know, all of the censorship stuff. They're not
rocking the boat, basically. They're happy to tow the Democratic
party line. And I think that's a problem because those are not
the people that have cultural currency online. If the Democrats
want to win, they need to start working with people that frankly
don't agree. Like they honestly, they just need to change their
policies. And so many >> this isn't true. This is the cringe
Hassan talking point that like, oh, nobody likes centrist libs.
Nobody likes libs at all. Actually, progressive, if you just
all became progressives, we'd win. We'd totally win right now.
Uh, this is just obviously not borne out in any actual election.
It's totally stupid. And you can see where she gets away from
the wired editorial staff who keep her on track. She immediately
starts spewing talking points, right, that aren't based in reality
>> things. But, um, but yeah, it's a very different. It's
more of a top down strategy where the Republican, even though
there's also a lot of dark money in the Republican world, it's
more bottom up. >> Totally. I mean, like, and and yet you
can, you know, kind of plant your flag either in like any faction
or party. You can say, "I'm a Democrat. I'm here to like, you
know, promote Democrats, defend Democrats, cheer for Democrats."
Yeah, I I can see some people saying, "Oh, okay, hold on. Blackhead
says, "A journalist rep and bias is important. A real journal
would have written up for this very differently."
No. Uh, all journalists have bias. Tons of journalists have bias.
the point. I think Taylor did a good job almost entirely of staying
within the the bounds of like journalistic ethics. I think the
by line the the by line and the first paragraph where she suggests
that they're being paid to tow the party line need to be changed
up slightly. Okay. I think they need to be changed up slightly.
That seems like uh Dem influencers who mostly echo the party
line are being funded is is like essentially the same sentiment.
Okay. But I don't I I think it's um it's far more defensible.
It's essentially the same sentiment though. >> And criticize
Republicans. You can say I'm in MAGA. I'm here to mock liberals
and the Democratic party and even like parts of the anti-Trump
Republican establishment. And you can build a big audience that
way. Big in terms of the number of people watching the amount
of money you're making. But I really question how much influence
you actually have because the people who's lying? Uh, all of
the people who have smeared Taylor Loren are the ones lying.
Uh, far more egregiously than she's lying. Far more egregiously.
Like they are straight up not looking at facts. They refuse to
look at any facts at all. And they are just egregiously lying,
trying to smear her, trying to slander her. And there's a bunch
of big influencers doing it. And participating that is gross
to me. You're just going to if you're going to trans if you're
just going to slander her because she wrote an article that is
slanted against you. I think that's insane. I think that's not
the world you should work in. I think it shouldn't be, oh, I
wrote this this article that's critical of these people, maybe
even a little too critical of these people that you go, oh yeah,
well, this [__] is taking dark money. How about you
just go, oh, she sucks. Here's like here's exactly where she
was wrong. They're not paying us to to do certain talking points.
They don't even get like editorial control over content, right?
Why not why not say that back? Oh, and she's Dude, yes. and the
uh the Brian Tyler Cohen bit where he goes and Candace Owens
says I respect Taylor Lens cuz she stands up for her beliefs
and Brian Tyler Cohen goes I don't know about you guys but I
wouldn't be I wouldn't trust anybody who's friends with Candace
Owens and Taylor sorry Candace Owens and Tucker Carlson
like that is just transparent
like bad faith webbing of her to these other people
like it's it's honestly so over the line it's like so egregious
that it's almost Uh, it's almost like immersion breaking. Like
I could totally believe Brian Tyler Cohen's like mostly trying
to fight for Dems and what's right in America. And then I see
that, right? I see it. It's just like, dude, what are you what
are you doing? No, unfortunately bad faith is a term you can
use and it is like obviously just a bad faith smear, right? You
take somebody saying, "I respect this one element of Taylor Loren,"
and you're like, "Yeah, she's best friends with this person."
We can all see what that is. people who are going to gravitate
toward those shows are people who already love the Democratic
party and want to hear validation. Right. And the problem with
the Democrats is not the people who love the Democratic party
as you say, it's even younger people, people on the left who
I think either stayed home or in some cases even voted for Trump
because of their anger over the Biden Harris support for the
genocide in Gaza by arming and funding Israel. So
>> what is the nature of these contracts in terms of the
constraints that it imposes on the con the the influencers who
they're paying? >> Yeah, there are some significant constraints
and certainly there are restrictions in these contracts that
I myself as a journalist would never feel comfortable agreeing
to. Um you know there are parts of the contract that talk about
that you cannot speak you cannot ever disclose the name of the
of the funer who's funding you. You can't disclose that you're
part of this program. um you know you have to funnel your bookings
like when you get a political booking say I get to interview
Zoron uh one creator said you know you have to then potentially
funnel that through chorus so chorus and the 1635
>> so this is a reference to the language of the contract
that we saw yesterday give me a second
now some people have taken issue with the term funnel okay so
contractor agrees to utilize the chorus newsroom to book engagements
disclose uh to disclose to the chorus newsroom personnel or uh
any engagements with government officials or other uh or others
on topics related to Chorus' policy agenda that contractor arranges
through other means and three collaborate fully with chorus regarding
all such separately arranged engagements. Right? So this to me
is saying yes you do have to actually talk to us work with us
on when you get these you have to you have to talk to us about
it right now. Does this say that they need to like get a an okay
from Chorus on this? No. But it says you need to actually collaborate
with us. I don't know what that means. Does that mean like letting
them have contact info? It doesn't seem to be explicit here or
I don't see what what's like what they're explicitly saying.
She said you potentially have to. I don't care what she said.
I'm looking at the contract right now that they're clearly referring
to in the wired article. Right. Chorus will provide contractors
with access to the Chorus newsroom which coordinates bookings
and engagement opportunities for creators with government officials,
policy and nonprofit experts and others whose expertise and experiences
are relevant to Chorus's progressive policy agenda. Contractor
agrees to utilize this newsroom to book engagements. Disclose
to the Chorus newsroom personnel any engagements with government
officials or others on topics related to Chorus' policy agenda
that contractor arranges through other means and collaborate
fully with Chorus regarding all such separately arranged engagements.
This is funneling at least the contacts through chorus, right?
I don't think there's any I really don't think there's like any
getting around this language. Now, I've seen some chorus creators
come out and go, "Well, I didn't do this." It's like, "Cool.
You didn't follow your contract."
But that's not even the article isn't even stating that this
is the way it is for all creators or this is like a a harshly
enforced policy. It says it's in the contract.
There it is in plain language in the contract. What is debunked
about this? Pisco said this is a false statement in the article.
I know Pisco argued on the term funnel. Uh I think when you look
at the number three, I don't think funnel is really disputable
here. Funneling the contacts. Now, not funneling as in like oh
it's a choke point for me to actually get this engagement to
to actually engage with this other person. But it is basically
saying I think I don't know what collaborate fully means for
sure. I feel like it's talking about we want the contact info
for that person who's willing to engage with creators like you,
somebody we actually have on. Debate Pisco. I don't need to debate
Pisco on this. I haven't talked to Pisco about this, but I'm
just saying that with this third clause, I think it's pretty
obvious that like funneling in terms of contacts, in terms of
leads, I think that's absolutely happening and it's absolutely
a goal of this program. No, no, it's not a false statement based
on this Tik Tocker just proved the statement in the article completely.
It's saying you cannot you should not be able to collaborate
sorry you should not be able to engage with any of these people
without collaborating fully with chorus
agrees to participate in newsroom something booking
opportunities at least twice a month it looks like also you need
to actually collaborate and go through their newsroom to do bookings
or something I think this is the last part we can't see it exactly
so yeah I I I think it's crazy to say that uh they were that
far off in their characterization of that section I don't think
it was that far >> Like they're trying to act as these
sort of like middlemen um and and kind of control access to certain
politicians, control who gets a voice online. Uh and yeah, that's
a problem. I think that it it you know there's concerns about
editorial independence. Um also there are restrictions on the
type of content that can be created with using chorus funds.
So if you use chorus funds, which there some of these creators
are getting $8,000 a month, it's pretty much probably most of
their budget for that month. um they can only sort of they can't
talk about specific candidates or causes without approval from
chorus and I think that alone is enough of >> there does
seem to be language in the contract that suggests okay I don't
I don't see anybody posting the language in the contract that
refutes this right >> a restriction for anybody that considers
themselves a journalist I would say to not do it and the fact
that they can't disclose it like all these content creators are
coming out now and they're like well what's the problem we're
getting paid and it's like well the problem is is that if my
article didn't come out, no one you guys would have kept taking
this dark money and no one knows where your money is coming from.
That's the problem. There's no >> to me to me, you know,
as as journal, >> the funniest part about this is I just
need to see how people react to uh one of like two or three of
these people, right? Because the funniest part of this to me
is that whole disclosure thing. A bunch of people are like, "Yeah,
in November 2024, I disclosed that I was partnered with Chorus."
They weren't receiving money. They don't say they're receiving
money, right? and they act like talking about working with Chorus
is the same as saying I'm getting money from Chorus. I've signed
a contract that limits how I operate, right? That has limits
in it on how I operate and I'm not telling you that's or sorry
and I've told you that by telling you in November 2024 before
I knew of the existence of the contract before I knew of the
existence of the program that I I somehow disclosed. It's it's
insane. It's insane. It's so stupid to say that that's disclosure.
What do you think of THR? Don't know who it is they are. most
obviously ethically offensive provision. I don't think journalists
are required to publish all their tax returns and say in like
every source of money, but if someone is paying you specifically
to >> Yeah. No, the per Yeah, Jerry, I get it. He said
the humanist report. I don't know who the humanist report is.
>> No idea. >> Influence what you're reporting or
what you're analyzing and what you're saying and you don't disclose
that to your audience. You keep that a secret.
That's a huge betrayal between yourself. >> Okay, grumpy
pants. Okay, I'll calm down. I'm going. I'm I'm uh I'm amped
up. Okay, I'll calm down. >> And the people who think that
you're telling them the unvarnished truth
>> and Glenn, these people had to attend daily messaging
uh check-ins. According to I can't remember if that was in the
Zoom call or the contract. It was a Zoom call. They talked about
the daily messaging check-ins. I I just I you know, I don't think
that journalists should have to go to messaging check-ins. Actually,
I don't think that we should promote.
>> That was the one thing from the alley thing that nobody
seemed to catch that I'm like, "Oh, that's interesting. What's
a daily messaging check-in? Why are you going to daily messaging
check-ins?" That's pretty interesting. >> Specific messaging.
You know, I I just there's a lot of things in here that to me,
you know, maybe are fine with a pro-democrat influencer, but
if you are presenting yourself as a journalist or presenting
yourself as like fact-based sort of like news coverer
person, uh, which a lot of these creators are, I I just think
it's it's not ethical. And yeah, I mean I agree like of course
look, no one's asking every journalist to post every single tax
receipt or you know every single thing, but this is a significant
amount of funding and this is an ongoing you know program that
is frankly operating in a very like high you know highinterest
space. So I think that they should have disclosed it just the
way that I disclose things. I'm in a you know reporting fellowship
right now. I disclose that like it's not that hard. >> Yeah.
I mean you know there's a big controversy in Brazil over uh Rumble.
Rumble is banned in Brazil and I write about the free speech
implications of that and at the end of every article, you know,
there's a note that says I have a program on Rumble and have
a relationship with Rumble. I would never dream of not disclosing
that while talking about the very entity um that is is part of
my income stream. Uh you know, but the the the the specific sentence
you wrote in the article about the content restriction, which
is incredibly creepy, quote, the creator now they the creators
themselves are saying, "Well, I don't let them control my content."
and it's fine, then then that's really simple to me, right? Just
get that provision removed, right? That's why I've kept saying
as long as the the provisions that Wired reviewed and and criticizes
that the entire Wired editorial staff or the Wired editorial
staff, not entire, but the Wired editorial staff reviewed all
of those sections that they've come and said, "Oh, yeah, this
is actually accurate. It seems like you can't reference these
things. You can't talk about these people. You need written express
consent to like talk about certain things. All of those
should be stripped out. If they're not relevant, if they're not
a part of this, right? Strip those out and then you're all good.
You're all good,
right? Well, I mean, I guess there's always the argument the
concern that if this was never raised, as Taylor said, that oh,
they just keep those in and you know, you hope that it, you know,
works on people. Maybe you never enforce it. But the thing is
is if it's in the contract, you have the ability to enforce it.
Even if you don't, right? You are you are presenting it to people
as if you're going to there's going to be a bunch of people who
will just follow that rule without ever thinking to violate it.
Who are part of this program join the incubator and who join
the incubator are expected to attend regular advocacy trainings.
Is there proof they are in every contract?
No. They've reviewed a couple contracts. If they aren't in every
contract, if that is not standard boilerplate language for their
contracts, why has nobody from Chorus felt the need to update
or correct the wired article? Why is why is there not a single
correction on this wired article? There is there are zero corrections.
This article has not been corrected.
If this article is lying about Chorus contracts, why has Chorus
not reached out to say, "Hey, you're lying about our contracts."
No retraction, no correction.
No retraction, no
Why? I thought BTC did say it was a lie. Sure, he's he's his
own creator. He can do whatever he wants, right? Chorus reached
out to update the article. I know the article is updated. It
includes it includes a reference to a slide from a Zoom caller
presentation where they said, "Here are the ways you can disclose
that you're that you can talk about this partnership." Now, I
haven't seen that published.
Why hasn't that been published? I don't know why that hasn't
been published. is very interesting. Yeah. No, it's not a retraction.
It adds to the article. It doesn't change any of the other elements
of the article. And I'm guessing the reason that they published
some slide that says here's how you can actually talk about it
is because explicitly they have a cause, a clause saying you
can't talk about it, right? Like that seems pretty obvious to
me that the only reason you include a slide saying here are the
approved ways to talk about this is because you have a clause
in your contracts that says this is the way sorry that you cannot
reference this. It's not a correction, Wired Rope. It is not
a correction. There is no part of the article that is actually
disputed or corrected. It is in addition to because Wired did
review the contracts and they reported on the contracts and they
reached out to Chorus for update for anything that they wanted
to include. Chorus did not respond. So when Chorus does respond
through this lawyer, through Graham, I forget Graham's last name,
okay? Or maybe Graham was his last name. But when they reach
out to this lawyer,
they add context to, oh, we kind of we updated one little tiny
piece of this, right? But it doesn't change the fact that in
the contracts, and they don't seem to dispute the fact that in
the contracts there was language saying you cannot disclose that
we're funding. You cannot disclose this partnership
and daily messaging check-ins. Now, on the list of the people
you've identified are some, I think, pretty recognizable >> Give
me uh one second. I'm just backing up a little bit. I got to
use the bathroom real quick. >> Is part of my income stream.
uh you know, but the the the specific sentence you wrote in the
article about the content restriction, which is incredibly creepy,
quote, "The creators who are part of this program join the incubator
and who join the incubator are expected to attend regular advocacy
trainings and daily messaging check-ins." Now, on the list of
the people you've identified are some, I think, pretty recognizable
names. David Pacman is a pretty
uh widely watched YouTube host. Um, there's Olivia Giulianiana,
that young abortion activist who got a lot of notoriety for speaking
out about abortion. I think has attended uh has been to the White
House several times when Biden was president. Uh, and then I
think Brian Taylor Green, is that his name? Brian >> Brian
uh Brian Tyler Cohen. >> Tyler Cohen uh is one of the I
guess co-founders of this. I presume he's he's making money from
it as well. And I saw the response of some of these people today
and nobody justified the fact that they were actually getting
money and then dutybound not to disclose it. They basically
in responding to you quite angrily acting as though they've been
defamed simply fabricated accusations that you didn't make and
then pronounced
>> Oh boy. Glenn is Glenn is kind of uh on the money here
with a lot of his stuff except for the part where he like I assume
Brian Tyler Cohen's making money off of this. I think there's
a there's a size you get to with programs like this where it
really is not at all
about the money, right? I don't think for Brian Brian Tyler Cohen
is trying to build up something where he's networking with politicians
and stuff, right? Why would he care about the money? He doesn't
give a about the money. He wants he wants influence. He wants
to be a part of the the big, you know, he wants to be sit at
the big boy table, okay? He wants a seat. That's what it's actually
about. They added a note at the bottom with a clarification.
I would call it a correction, but they say clarification. it's
not a correction.
If it's a correction, it has to say we were wrong in this part
of the article. And so I would just ask where does it say they
were wrong?
Because from what I can tell, most of the claims about the article
are saying the contracts we reviewed state this. The contracts
we reviewed state that. Right? So how are you correcting if the
contracts you reviewed actually say that? There's nothing to
correct. So, you'd have to find the corrected part of the article
where they go, "We were wrong on this and we need to actually
update and show." But I don't see that happening. They just added
additional context. That's not a correction or a
Taylor Loren's tweeting earlier today. Earlier today, I heard
from a right-wing media reporter yesterday that Chorus is pitching
hip pieces on me. I wonder if this is this story, which repeats
the false claim that I'm funded by the 1630 fund. I am not, is
part of that wellunded smear campaign. goes on, "This is nasty
work. The majority of creators in the program are white. Two
centrist Dem influencers have been hurling abuse at me. Dem black
influencers have been hurling abuse at me for days, spreading
outright lies, and now this narrative is being laundered in hit
pieces. All creators were asked for comment prior to the publication,
too." So, I thought this was crazy. Okay, this is insane.
Taylor Ren's called out by black activists for allegedly suspect
article. You want to talk about a lack of journalistic integrity?
Christopher Smith, come on down.
That is so much more insane than what Taylor Loren published.
Okay, that's
because we can all tell the implication here is that Taylor Loren
is racist. So, I'm just going to keep pointing out that Taylor
Loren is 10 times 100 times a thousand times more honest than
the people criticizing her in reverse. Okay, that's nuts.
What publication? I believe this is the Mediite article. Yes.
Is this Maybe it's not the mediaite article. Hold on. Let me
see if we can see any indication here.
I'm I wouldn't be shocked if this was already changed. Taylor
Loren called out by black activists. I'm looking it up over here.
Give me a second. This is
newsbreak.com.
What? What the [__] is this? Hold on. Let me Let
me see if I can find it. Z Hip Hop Cleveland
by Christopher Smith. I can't. Yeah. Z Hip Hop Cleveland by Christopher
Smith. Okay. All right. Not exactly the uh most legitimate of
publications, but to be fair, the author didn't write doesn't
write the headline. Oh, does the author write the by line, by
the way? Do you guys know? Does the author write the by line?
Cuz I thought that was possibly another defense of Taylor is
the by line of the article is what gets her in trouble. If she
didn't write the by line, right? If the editorial staff wrote
the by line, then I'd say that's not even Taylor's claim. I think
that's where she gets in the most trouble is with the by line,
to be honest. But this is like an insane insane insinuation.
Okay. Lorenz was called out on social media for specifically
targeting black creators such as So these people said, "Isn't
it? It's so disgusting how she puts us in danger
as well as other non-binary trans creators."
That's crazy, dude. This is embarrassing, right? I think we can
all tell that this is embarrassing. It's amazing how vocal these
lib influencers can be when their bag is threatened. I dude I
think there's like a lot of react there's a lot of reasons for
like reactive um like just reactionary I reactionary responses
like very reactive responses to this. I think for like Hutch
and a couple people around him, it's the progressive victory
thing, right? They went through getting questioned about progressive
victory. They didn't like it and so they see it happening again
and they'll automatically jump to defend with some of the same
bad talking points they had back then. Okay. Yeah. So anyway,
this was all this is all going back to a crystal ball tweet.
She quotes this and says, "I see centrists are back to weaponizing
identity politics in order to quash legitimate criticism. Gross
True. True. See, black cat, this is what we know you you want,
right? You you don't care about honesty. This is why we are disgusted
by you and the people you associate with. You don't care about
honesty. You just care about like narratives is is transparent.
It's very obvious, right? But thank you for admitting it. I It's
just It's so clear. It's so clear. I bet you you think that there's
no proof that Destiny's minor, right? Are you still on that page
right now that there's no proof Destiny minor? I saw you arguing
with that. I saw you arguing that with somebody on Twitter recently.
That's proven. Okay, that's proven. There's more proof of that
than the idea that the US went to the moon. Okay, I'm more confident
that Destiny a minor than that the US landed on the moon. Maybe
not actually. I actually don't know what the evidence is for
landing on the moon. I just accept that institutions tell me
it happened. But I'm telling you there's like a
chance that he's minor.
So, I just like that people don't want to inform themselves.
They just want their narrative to be amplified.
I appreciate it. I appreciate people being honest about it. Destiny
does not have on his computer. Of course, I don't have that video.
Of course, I don't have it on my computer.
That's his laugh, by the way. Oh, disgusting. See, Sam, I would
never have something like that on my streaming PC.
Okay, it's uh it's some wild stuff. Oh, here here they are. I
see leftists are back to throwing black people under the bus
to push far-left propaganda hit pieces. Gross tactic.
Like this is just transpar. It's so transparent. It's so gross.
I I will say I hope you are getting paid to do this to like to
try to run with stuff like this. I would say I hope you're getting
paid. If you're not getting paid, you should be okay. Somebody
should be paying you if you're not. This is a lot of work to
put in to not get any money out of it. All right. All right.
All right. Where are we going next? Oh, what is this? Why am
I being given this? Christopher Smith, why am I being given this?
I have horrible ADHD and Indica's really Why? I I have no evidence
that this is the same person. Whoever sent me this, I have no
evidence that it's the same person at all. I'm not I'm not going
to say that. Nah. Nah, I don't know that that guy wrote the article.
Okay. I don't know. I don't know that he wrote the article >> to
deny to denounce those or reject those as untrue. So, I think
they have a clip from David Pacman.
pull up the crystal tweet. It's relevant to all that
Somebody wasn't watching the stream. We did pull it up. I see
San Francisco back to weapon. Yeah, we pulled it up. We talked
about it. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Is there another crystal tweet? Did
I miss one? This is all on the off the back of the crystal ball
tweet. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. We got it. We're back to the Taylor
Ren video with Glenn Greenwald. >> Responding to you that
I just want to show a short clip um and then ask you to respond.
This kind of support for creators is exactly what I've been advocating
for. Now, the article is riddled with inaccuracies, and they're
not minor inaccuracies.
First and
clear and obvious lie.
The only inaccuracy that I've seen that I've seen proven out
in any way is or not even proven out. The only inaccuracy that
I can see to call out is the the by line in the first paragraph
saying they're being paid to push the party line.
This group has nothing to do with the DNC. People writing saying
the the the Democratic party is telling people what to say. At
its base, the group has nothing to do with the DNC. Period. Number
two, >> oh boy, >> I do not get clearance for anything
I say. I do not run interview questions by anyone at chorus.
Now, Tyler, I read your article this morning when it came out
and then I read it again. I'm preparing to speak to you about
it and every a lot of people and I stopped it as well. We're
all like, where in the article did you say this was the DNC funding
it? Where in the article do you say that they have to submit
what they want to say every day first and get approval? like
he's denying things that you didn't say and ignoring the things
that you actually did. >> And listen, for small influencers,
I could understand you, you know, can't read. You know, we're
aware of Willie Mack. We're aware of people like Hutch. I understand
that they can't read, that they have difficulty with these things,
okay? And I'm empathetic to that. But for somebody like David
Pacman or Brian Tyler Cohen to present this the way they have,
I think is super okay. These guys make a ton of money. They pay
research staff to do their job for them. Could you not like do
you need to hire a second research staff to make sure you don't
just openly lie about this
Do you need like a whole second staff to like check you need
a red team to make sure your first team isn't just um but
I mean this thing like this is not a DNC arm like right technically
it's not an arm of the DNC but these are people who are active
in Democratic party and liberal politics that's who they're funding
this >> also chorus go >> oh sorry to interrupt it
drives me insane Glenn because chorus is was funded go read the
great New York Times I think Ken Benzinger wrote it a piece on
chorus after they launch their election that Brian Tyler Cohen
is talking specifically about solving the Democrats messaging
problem.
she knows. She knows. She knows. She knows.
Oh, we should go watch. Okay, we should go. Did she watch you?
Maybe she does. Cuz I know. I pointed out. Okay. Although she
probably just read the New York Times piece, but I pointed out
that Yeah, it's right after the election. Brian Tyler Cohen goes
on Destiny's stream. He cams up and says, "We have to fix Democrat
messaging. Republicans are locked step on messaging and we need
to get Dems locked step on messaging the way they are. Right.
And then they go, "Oh, guys, this has nothing to do with the
Democratic Party." Whoa. Why? Where did you get the idea that
this has anything to do with the Democratic Party? That's crazy.
>> Their their uh their pitch decks have all this stuff
about how the Democrats messaging problem is broken and they're
here to fix it and all this stuff. So, yes, they are not
>> Oh my god. Can I get the pitch decks? Can we just Why
Why won't Taylor just publish all this stuff? publish it all.
Let me see everything. I want to see all of it. Okay, >> the
DNC, but they serve the Democratic establishment and that is
what they exist to do. And to sort of act like they don't or
they're some like neutral party is just absurd.
Yeah, I didn't check, so I can't say definitively, but I will
bet any amount of money that when those disclosures came out
about Tenant Media, which was linked to Russians in some sketchy
way, paying people like Tim P and Dave Rubin and Benny Johnson,
I'll bet any amount of money that uh David Pacman and probably
some of the other people on the list were expressing all kinds
of outrage and indignation at the ethical transgressions of not
having disclosed this and not knowing where their sourcing came
from. What can you tell us though about who they were? Now, the
tenant stuff is much easier to put into I I think there's some
similarities. There are, but the tenant stuff is just way easier
to slide into the pile of you're taking money from a foreign
adversary. Um, you are helping them in laundering their new,
you know, their new network, right?
Which is going to be tenant because RT is sanctioned now can
operate in the US. You're helping them launder that new network.
Like it's it's obviously going to I don't even think Glenn's
entirely wrong there, but it's just obviously like a difficult
line to walk down and and act like, oh, they're the exact same
thing because you're always going to have the foreign adversary
thing there and it's a little sketchy. Okay. >> Is providing
the funding like is this just grassroots funding or are there
big donors particularly behind it? >> Oh, Taylor posted
the pitch deck. Did she? Chorus is not is nonpartisan is a new
one. If if that's true, then why do the company's own confidential
decks that I obtained frame chorus as a solution to Dem's messaging
problems? And why is it why is that also exactly how chorus framed
itself in the media before my story came out? We are 10 years
behind. We're losing the narrative. Conservative progressive.
Oh, I can see Democrats fume over weak early response to Trump.
It's a war. Do Democrats get that? What the are Democrats doing?
Democrats wonder where their leaders are? Oh, yeah. Well, we
just knew this right off the bat. We just knew this right off
the bat. The idea that Chorus is not partisan or nonpartisan,
non-political, that's nuts. Okay,
that's nuts.
I And and people, by the way, won't call out the chorus people
who are saying this, who are clearly just working off the script,
right? These people all got the same script on what to say. They
watch these people salute like actual robots. Like they're the
Tesla robots at a Elon Musk, you know, ego monument, okay? One
of his Tesla presentations. All right. They all salute. They're
all getting in the bus at the same time. And everybody, everybody
on the Dem side, everybody who's like remotely liberal just goes,
"Oh, this is totally normal." And this, "Yeah, this is all fine,
guys." Yeah, that is a totally nonpartisan nonpolitical organization
for sure that only funds Democratleaning
political media creators. Okay. Yeah, for sure. For sure. Oh,
definitely. Yeah, I believe that 100%. They're totally not lying
at all. >> This is not This is the opposite of grassroots
funding. You cannot get more opposite. Like the 1630 fund again
is this powerful powerful dark money group that that allocates
hundreds of millions of dollars. Um I think it was 2023 or 2024,
their largest donor gave $50 million. One donor. Second largest
donor, I believe, was 30 million or 40
>> Okay. A fun question for Taylor would be if this money
if there's if they're just flush with this money on the Republican
side, what would be your solution to using this kind ego monument
monument to his ego, whatever the his presentations are. I was
trying to think of something. There's there's a way to describe
that. Uh but I can't think of it off the top of my head. If if
this money's so prevalent in the Republican side, how Taylor
would you spend similarly funded money, okay, on the Dem side
or on the progressive side? How is that supposed to be split
up? How is that supposed to be doowled out? Because like I could
you could you give me a better way to do it? I actually have
no idea. I would love to know cuz obviously you probably don't
want them to operate at like a billion to5 billion disadvantage,
right? You don't want the people who are going to do that on
your side. So you don't want people on your side operating at
a $5 billion disadvantage every cycle. That would be crazy, right?
5 10 20 I don't even know how much it is when you take all super
PACs put together, right? you don't want that. So, what are you
what's the solution? I would love to know what her solution would
be because she's just saying like this is obviously bad. I think
even if they disclosed, she would still have an issue with it
if it was not, you know, including some of the pro Palestine
anti-ionist voices, people like Hassan, I think she'd still have
an issue with it. >> Um, it sort of went down from there
down to like 13 million. Like, these are people with massive
amounts of money and massive amounts of influence. You cannot
give $50 million
to a dark money organization and not expect something or not
expect to have your policy agenda realized. And I put all of
these questions to the 1630 fund and to chorus. Um I asked them,
you know, who who is this? Like do you know, you know, does it
make you nervous? Also, what what role did 1630 have in picking
the specific influencers? you know, for all we know, the the
person that gave $50 million to uh 1630 could have had some sort
of input uh on the on the ideology expressed, you know, that
creators were allowed ideology of the creators allowed in this
program. So, it's >> my my real concern would be
um what happens if they do start exerting that that force? What's
the what's the structure? Do they have any say? Can they shut
this down if they just shut the tap off? Like I don't know like
where because to me TPUSA started probably from a place like
a a good place and then they started exerting you know like their
their donors started exerting some some what would you call it
leverage over them right so that that would be my concern is
what happens when they do say actually those people who are talking
about Gaza right now kick them out kick them out I give $100
million every cycle to 1630 if you don't kick those people out
I'm not doing it anymore for an example, right? TPUSA was never
good. I don't think it was ever good, but I don't know that this
is good yet. Okay, we we'd have to see. This is kind of getting
killed in its cradle or it's kind of getting brought up in its
cradle. We don't really know how good this might be. We have
no idea. >> Just it's just shocking to me and I just think
that we need a lot more transparency and it's and then you see
the liberals double down and say, >> "Oh, I'm going to
I'm going to shut the Twitch stream off though. We're going over
to kick only." Kick only, guys, if you're if you're following.
Okay. Go over to kick. Go over to kick.com/jok.
Not doing Twitch for any longer. All right. Thank you for being
on the Twitch stream early on. Don't forget to throw Twitch primers,
guys. Twitch.tv/jok
with an underscore. All right.
Don't forget primers over there. Twitch.tv/jok_.
That's it. That's it right there. Throw primers. Throw primers.
No Hassan raid. No Hassan raid. We're not waiting for a Hassan
raid tonight. All right. We're not doing it. All right. Let me
uh let me shut this down right here. Multi streaming off. Boom.
Boom. All right. >> Oh, no. Well, this is this is what
the the Republicans do. Again, as you mentioned, they criticize
the Republicans for that constantly. And as they should, rightfully
so. I criticize Tim P. I criticize all those people that took
that dark money. You should never take significant amount of
money from people that you don't you don't know where it's coming
from, especially a shady group like that. So, I can't remember
the original question. I'm on a tangent, but it's very it's it's
very >> No, but the question is like, who are these big
donors? But there's a dark money group. We don't know, right?
That's what it means to have dark Huh? Unless Unless Taylor Loren
is criticizing and then we'll find out that Pier Midar is one
of the donors. Okay. Seemed like they're pretty quick to out
Pierro Midiar as one of the donors to try to smear Taylor Loren
is some kind of hypocrite. Right. It doesn't have to be disclosed.
You would never know. But Pierro Midiar, oh yeah, he actually
is a funer of the 1630 fund, guys. Money.
>> And that's the problem. If you give $50 million, we
should know who you are. >> All right. Let me ask you this,
Teller, because I want to ask this question in in a delicate
way because I don't want to be misunderstood. $8,000 a month
is in to most people it's a lot of money. I mean, it's a $96,000
a year salary for basically just being an influencer. Most people
would would love to have that. Um, either as their main job or
as supplemental income, but I understand pretty well the economics
of online
uh content creating because it's something I I do and have done
for a few years now. And just let's stick with David Pacman for
a second. I'd be willing to also bet an enormous amount of money
that he's making well over seven figures. Like for sure a million
dollars a year between his income from YouTube, between his sponsors
on his show, and between his patrons paying money into that Patreon
account every month. I would say it's well over a million dollars,
probably over two. I don't want to speculate any further, but
it's a lot of money.
Why would somebody be willing to jeopardize their integrity for
in the context of what he's making? I don't mean for So he's
talking about Pac-Man, right? I think I heard Pacman. So for
me, Pacman obviously that was my first question. I was like obviously
Pacman's not on the same contracts as everybody else. There's
just no way. It's not $8,000 is not worth it for David Pacman.
I think he said pretty quickly he's not a part of that program,
right? He's not a part of the program. He's like a mentor. That's
not something he's participating in. most people have been in
the context of he's making kind of a relatively small amount
of money. >> Absolutely. I I know this is something that
I was curious about too and I asked these questions of the creators
that I tried to get in touch with like the you know the the higher
profile ones I I sort of tried to ask even the creators that
were lower profile like the creators that I did ultimately speak
to in the program. I was like this is not the vast amount of
money in the grand scheme of things. Um but I think it's this
desire to be close to the establishment. I think it's access.
Um, chorus again provides access to lawmakers and the Democratic
establishment. And I don't know, I mean, I I think they just
want to be part of a group. And I and I empathize with that.
Like, listen, I not everything, you know, sometimes you do want
to be part of a cohort. These creators are clearly some sort
of a click where they're all defending each other, you know,
in the comment section and stuff. But I don't know. I think it's
kind of shocking that they are willing to make such compromises
for such a low amount of money in their in in their sort of world
because you're right.
Uh, so I guess with Pac-Man, it's hard to take a look at his
response and say that that wasn't, you know, pretty compromising,
right? His response was pretty insane in my opinion. And so maybe
that's what Taylor's referring to. I don't think he took $8,000
a month to sign that contract. I just don't see how that could
possibly be worth it for him. >> 86,000. I mean, look,
that's a huge amount of money for a journalist even, but like
in their world, these are people that that have these giant revenue
streams. Um, and it is revealing that they're willing to sell
out for so >> right? I'm not saying I'd be more empathetic
if they were getting huge amounts of money to like do something
as unethical as this, but you know, just from like their own
self-interest, I don't understand why they'd risk its disclosure
for what for them is is a relatively small amount of money. All
right. All right. Now, hold on. That's 19 minutes. Let me go
19 minutes or so into his Taylor Lorenza interview on Rumble.
What? Minute 12 or so. issues that you have been focused on that
not many in Brazil that are just >> outright state censorship
and state control over the uh reporting as well. Let me switch
gears a little bit
and stuff but I don't know I think it's kind of shocking that
they are willing to make such compromises. >> Sorry, we've
got more to this on Rumble >> for these to like do something
>> giant revenue streams. Um and it is revealing that they're
>> I think this is about where we switch over. Okay. >> Right.
I'm not saying I'm I'd be more empathetic if they were getting
huge amounts of money to like do something as unethical as this,
but you know, just from like their own self-interest, I don't
understand why they'd risk its disclosure for what for them is
is a relatively small amount. All right, congratulations on that
article. I think it's uh very good reporting. I think it's important
uh reporting as well. Let me switch gears a little bit uh
to in general the topic that I think probably gave rise to some
of the disagreements and acrimony that you and I have had over
the years which is the
>> of online censorship but I want to leave that aside
at least for the moment. >> Why is Glenn Glenn got a contract
from Rumble to do his show on Rumble? Like he gets paid by Rumble.
He's got an extra he's got like an extra deal from them. I I
didn't realize. Okay. Apparently the rest of this is just different
topic. So, we can shift. We can shift back.
All right. Huh. There's uh what else do we got here? Got like
a couple different things here. Okay. I might go through the
hutch thing. I was going to start from a different point of view
though.
>> And then >> the voice of a generation.
He's weighed in. Okay. Brand new video dropped yesterday. Not
a brand new video really. Let's see what he has to say. Okay.
Let's see
what the man himself has to say. a dark line. >> I'm I'm
kind of interested. Vosch is always a wild card to me because
Vosch committed a lot harder to progressive victory than Hassan
did. And so I think he's got some experience from there. He's
seen progressive victory kind of fund the more progressive side
of this as well. I I don't know exactly what his take's going
to be based on the title. Uh oh, damn influencers are in big
trouble. Maybe we have some idea. Maybe we do.
>> We'll see. We're going to keep looking into it. Democratic
influencers. An initiative aimed at boosting Democrats online
offers influencers up to 8,000 a month to push the part. Only
$8,000
a month. Jesus Christ. Kla Harris raises and then somehow manages
to spend billions in a three-month presidential campaign and
you're putting up five figure like uh content creator buyout
salaries. Jesus Christ. They have to siphon the rest off to themselves.
Yeah, I guess it's not cheap paying for the salaries of 50,000
consultants in DC. Oh my god. 8,000 a month for one person is
crazy though. Not really. Not for this level of remember that
when it was found out that there was that one YouTube channel
that was paying Tim Pool and a far a few other farright uh content
creators like what was like like a million a year. How much was
it? >> I believe it was 400k a month, right? 100k a week,
400k a month. Basically like 105k an episode for Tim Pool.
So what? 400k times 12 is 4.8 million. an obscene amount of money
per year. It was like $400,000 a month or something.
>> Ridiculous. For like video a week, you know, like >> But
that's Tim P. That's like one of the at the time before that
came out, one of the biggest right-wing influencers that existed.
Yeah. It was not exclusive. >> Secretive program aimed
at bolstering democratic messaging on the internet. But the contract
sent uh to them from Chorus, the nonprofit arm of a liberal influencer
marketing platform, came with some strings. mandated extensive
secrecy about disclosing their payments, restrictions on what
kind of political content the creators could produce. Let me
guess, you can't criticize Israel. I'm just I'm just going to
pitch it. I'm just going to pitch it. Let me guess. You can't
criticize
Israel. That's my No.
See, this is the thing. None of these people would have been
able to survive when censorship was at its height. None of these
people would have been able to survive. Okay? You cannot just
You can't just out of intuition blame it on the Okay, guys. We
can't We don't want to do that. We don't want to do that. All
right. We don't want to do that. I did like, by the way, I did
like though that Brian Tyler Con and David Pacman both are like,
"Of course I've talked about how disgusting the the the conduct
by Israel has been in in Gaza. Of course I've of course I've
mentioned that that there are terrible atrocity. You go look
at their YouTube channels. There's literally nothing. There's
like literally nothing. They're just total barren wastelands
of the topic, right? I will say there's a little bit something
there that if you are something of a talented noticer, you might
pick up. Okay, you might pick it up. You notice just, oh, these
guys said they really push back again. Well, they haven't though,
but you know, but just blaming the reflexively. I don't know
that we're down with that. It's a little this could be a little
weird. All right. or probably they felt in some some like PR
kind of way, you know, like well you should criticisms offered
to Israel should be done with full Israel does not equate to
the Yeah, it does. When I'm sorry there's an overlap between
Judaism, the ethnicity and the state of Israel and trying to
disconnect them in some way is okay. There's a massive overlap
between these things. If you're just blaming Israel for stuff,
you can have criticisms of Israel that don't reflexively include
Jewish people, okay? That don't reflexively include the ethnicity.
But I'm telling you that when I say I typically mean like I'm
not even talking about the ethnicity. I'm talking about the word
when I say what you think of. And to me, I think a lot of people
tie that to Israel. I think that is intrinsically tied in a way
that you can't really break. I don't think it necessarily makes
you anti-Semitic
unless you go there a lot with no evidence. Okay. then it can
be >> Full respect of the, you know, the party line. Should
we send a joint email or are they just going to send things separately
and hope they change everything for everyone? Lorenzo, a non-binary
creator in Columbus, Ohio. Vos, I do not recommend we take this
article at face value. Okay, we're like one paragraph into it.
Why? I mean, we we we have to like we have to read it before
we can I in what way? Wired's pretty they put out some good stuff.
>> Yeah, that's actually okay. Vos gets it. Like I'm reading
something in a in a publication that I feel comfortable has sourced
and has sourced and reviewed all the claims made and doesn't
want to get >> Admittedly, Taylor Loren's uh I I I think
has at times demonstrated less than spectacular. >> I don't
even understand what you just meant by that. That when I'm like
basically if your first thing is to go I bet these people don't
even criticize Israel, right? I'm just like I think that's going
in a direction. It's not always anti-semitic.
I wouldn't even say Bosch. I don't think Bosch is anti-semitic.
What I'm saying is that
people would clap you for anti-semitism for that kind of thing.
Okay. A few years ago before Trump got back into office, I think
people would clap you on that one. If you're just constantly
going to the first as like a thing, I think um I think people
used to get clapped on that in a way that they don't quite anymore.
And people have gotten used to that and I don't think they would
have survived. >> A political Pac-Man response. You want
me to take Pac-Man over a Wired article? is wait is your >> go
off king. Let's go. You want me to trust David Pacman over a
wired article? You Thank you, Vos. Thank you, Vos. Thank you.
Okay, Porter Beller. Yeah, I'm I'm also a little bit joking.
Okay, I understand the separation. >> Pac-Man response.
You want me to take Pac-Man over a Wired article? Is Wait, is
your is your
descent here because Pac-Man disagrees? I mean, we can take a
peek. We can take a peek. Where's your 8K payout from the DNC?
Honestly, honestly, they would never give it to me. Pac-Man's
on the list. Yeah, the influencers in the chat collectively had
at least 13 million followers across social platforms. Uh, ultimately
the group didn't really make much make much progress. Uh, V email
change. Vosch is thriving.
Yeah. Yeah. Holy, Bosch lost weight. Yeah, Vos is thriving. Vosch
did a stream from outside. He was hiking. He was totally gassed
trying to hike up like a hill. Okay, but he did a stream. He
did an IRL stream outside hiking. Okay, it was crazy. He tried
to talk about some stuff. He tried to do like a Peter Zian impression.
Okay, it didn't go well. He was huffing and puffing the whole
time, but good on him, you know. Good on him.
>> I don't feel strong
a Gen Z news influencer who had been called the Gen Z Walter
Konite. Okay, posted to the chat. They aren't going to modify
anymore. Seems like it's take it or leave it. $8,000 a month
is so when it was out for years to work with influencers, Joe
Biden snubbed several prominent content creators after they lightly
criticized the administration over its policies on climate change,
COVID, Gaza, and the Tik Tok ban. Content creators who challenged
Kla Harris, including Hassan [__] a well-known influencer
on the left, were similarly unwelcome at campaign events. That's
true. After the Democrats lost November, they faced a reckoning.
The party had failed to successfully navigate a new media landscape.
it. Look, there's there's just no you can hem andhaw about Hassan
being a fairweather friend to the Democrats in the best of days,
but there is no arguing the fact that Democrats have gotten absolutely
dogwalked by Republicans when it comes to cultivating relationships
in new media. Like it is insane that Democrats still think that
like pitching an idea on on MSNBC or something is how you get
information across these days. or these embarrassing initiatives
they come up with every six months about like appealing to young
people and their ideas like well what if we gave another few
million over to consultants who will tell us to I don't know
whatever guys I know what we have to do okay we have to pay not
so aerodite and counterpoints to come down here and tell us that
we should say more all right can we pay not so eroderite and
counterpoints to run media for us they clearly have a mind for
this thing okay they clearly got a mind for it they're figuring
it out I that video is like it's just going going to stand over
time as like an indication that the Dems are in for like a like
a 10-year drought or something. Like, we just lost this election.
I know who we need to go to. Connor
and Kyla. They'll solve it for us, guys. They got it. I know
they got it. All right. Give me a second. I think I'm going to
jump in uh Collins here for a second. I think Beckett's around.
Ginger Dickers has he's around. Okay,
he's hanging out. See if he's going to hop on. I should message
him back.
we get too far into the Vosch article or Vosch video, I'm not
sure I'm going to do too much of the Vosch video. I maybe want
his reactions to stuff, but I think him just generally reading
the article. I'm not sure, you know, we might watch his ending
here.
I think we've kind of we've we've read the article enough that
we don't need to reread the article every single time. I would
say
dark woke is the only path. I don't even know what that means.
I think there's plenty of room for liberals in all of this. I
don't I don't really buy that. uh that you have to get through
this with like one side of the horseshoe or the other. I say
liberalism is depressing right now though. Like there's nothing
more depressing than watching your your your uh what do you call
it like um standard of living fall and then watching liberals
come and tell you actually like the GDP is going up so you shouldn't
really feel that bad. There's nothing there's nothing more like
contemptable than that, right? Yeah, I know. I know you can't
get a job when when like the same degree program you just went
through like 5 years ago. uh they could get jobs for like $100,000
out of high school or sorry out of college and now you can't
get a job. Your job has been like totally totally taken out.
Okay, but that's that's good. That's innovation.
No, it's not. [__] you. I don't like that. I don't
like that. Nobody likes being told that [__] It's
blackpilling to anyone listening to them. I think it really is.
Ah, dude. I hate to say, but there's like a there's a Fuentes
rant on this that's so good that I don't know if I'll ever be
able to find it, but he basically talks about like Yeah, he basically
talks about like a whole bunch of
how do I explain it? Shout out Shout outs Will Stansel. True.
Oh, you join Oh, no, no, no. Hold on. Wait. Am I Is my No. Oh,
what the hell? Shouldn't these guys just be able to join this
channel? Hello. Can you not see this channel? Hello. Hello. >> Oh,
I can. Can I join? Do I have pumps? Can I just randomly join?
I didn't realize that. Maybe I >> just randomly join. As
does apparently apparently Dicker's hanging out too. Oh no, it's
not Dickers. That's definitely Kathy. You want to say hi to Kathy?
I'm going to drag Kathy in for a second. Hey Kathy, how's it
going? >> For a second. >> Hello, this is Dickers.
>> Is it Dickers?
>> Is that your British accent? Is that what we're doing?
>> On Dickers. We just talked right now.
Yeah, I just spent like two hours talking to dickers about this
uh chorus stuff. I'm fascinated. I only heard about it like yesterday
morning, bro. >> What a [__] show.
>> I actually got sent If you want to hop in the um if
you want to hop in the presentation here. I got sent a clip from
you uh yesterday. Watch it on the stream. Give me a second. I'll
find it >> Apparently, you are not going to be >> Is
this my Is this my anime? Yes, my anime anime villain speech.
Yes. Let's [__] go. >> If this happens again
and it is discovered, it will be worse.
That's the incentive. It'll be worse. Like like >> Oh,
for context, this is Becket talking about progressive victory.
>> Next time there's no, oh, we can talk this out. If someone
does this again, there is no we can talk about this again. We
know now. We know what people's standards are. So if people are
like worried about being why we keep things secret like But you
think like if anyone thinks Becket's been rather harsh, I swear
to God, you have seen nothing out of me yet. Okay. I I don't
often get angry and I don't often get researchy and I don't often
start pulling things. But when I do, when I am activated, I have
in the I have been up for like 60, 70, 80 hours deal with this
[__] I will do everything in my power to tear down
anyone who [__]
This is the dirtiest anime speech I've ever heard in my life,
by the way. >> Dude, I was awake for so long. I meant it
though. I meant it though. I mean, like, so cuz I think the question
was, did I mean this? Well, obviously. Yeah. I mean, the minute
I heard about this and I was made aware of it, I' I've been looking
to talk about it and uh yeah, [__] the so um absolutely
I'm covering this and I think there's probably some interesting
maybe things we can do. I was talking to Dickers about potentially
like comparison uh like comparisons between people's content
who we know were associated with this for the daily talking points.
>> See how much of an impact it had.
>> Yeah. The thing so I don't know if you're aware the
there's the daily talking points and then there's I think a weekly
uh advocate training which they said was going deep on a policy
issue,
>> So I think that's the alley girl says that's going deep
on a policy issue. She showed her calendar. I don't know if you
saw any of that. >> Yeah. Yeah, I saw >> they showed
like the Yeah. the mornings where they do the daily messaging
check-ins and then the weekly I guess advocacy training and then
apparently
>> an hour half an hour a week on like here's how to set
up your lighting which is amazing. Okay. I think >> I I
mean I think one of the most telling things is you can see the
Twitter statements about the article itself are like word for
word. >> Yes. Yes. That's the first point I was going to
bring up cuz I just brought it up 20 minutes ago. Okay. How is
everybody Everybody comes out and they're like, "This is totally
the the now debunked article by Taylor Loren, right? This person
who's a total hypocrite on dark money because they take money
from the 1630 fund, too." And it's like, "You are all lying.
Like, I'm watching you all lie in unison." Dude, there's another
thing.
>> There's another thing a couple of them did. And and
people amplified this. They're like, "Oh, yeah. When this when
this thing was first built, when we first discussed Chorus in
November, you know, 2024, November 20th, 2024, I said I was going
to work with Chorus. That's me disclosing it to you." No, it's
not. No, it's not. You in a nonmonetary relationship with this
thing that you don't even know. It's like a totally amorphous
thing. It had just been started days earlier. You don't even
know what you're signed up for. You saying you want to work with
them is not you saying you're getting a monetary stipend from
them to attend some of these things. and and possibly, you know,
have some restrictions to the things you can say. Now, I don't
think those restrictions are strong and I'm not even sure they
want to stand by those, right? It's possible that that's just
like legal ease that got thrown into contracts. They don't stand
by it and they'll remove it, right? In which case, I'm like kind
of fine with things possibly. But, dude, the response where they
just slander Taylor Loren is kind of insane to me. Yeah, I saw
I think I just caught the end of Going where it's like, you know,
I don't want to be associated with anyone who's friends with
Tucker Carlson because there's like a random clip of Candace
Owens being like, "Yeah, I respect Taylor Rens." Absolutely.
Like the claim of Tucker Carlson is in some way like Taylor Ren
is associated with Tucker Carlson is a crazy thing to I'm not
a fan of Taylor Loren. I don't particularly like Taylor Ren,
but like dude, they're they're trying awfully hard to discredit
her and it it makes all of this look very suspicious. What's
your actual Okay, so for me, cuz one of the reasons obviously
I'm being uh like this was brought to my attention was the PV
stuff. My position was always transparency.
So, for example, when Wick took money from Rebellion Pack for
sponsored streams, I had no issue with that. I was like, "That's
fine." >> Yeah. Yeah. And it was because it was all in
the public. It was very upfront. That's absolutely fine. I think
that the word dark money gets like the phrase dark money gets
thrown around an awful lot and most people don't even really
know what what it means. Um I mean like I think I think you know
the example I used on Dick stream is Wick did a panel talking
about dark money and how he hated dark money while receiving
dark money. It's like obviously obviously you just you know the
word sounds bad. Um but yeah, I mean is that pretty much where
you're sat with this?
um disclosures and then I I think obviously there's uh some clauses
in the contract with regards to networking how that has to run
through this thing with regards to uh sorry the the getting politicians
there's like some clauses in the contract that seem to suggest
that you have to collaborate with chorus directly if you are
talking to a politician or a policy expert of some kind right
to me that's probably them trying to collect all of these people
as leads so that they can continue to connect them with other
influencers right >> becoming like a repository of those
Yeah, I think they're definitely trying to become middlemen.
There's two points I brought up on Dickers. Firstly, with the
contract itself, the way the contract is written is >> anytime,
and I'm I'm paraphrasing here, but I think this is as close as
I can get word to word, anytime you have a conversation um outside
of this kind of newsroom thing. Yeah. So, it's like very quick
uh very particularly any engagements with government officials
or others on topics related to chorus' policy agenda that contractors
arrange through other means. Now, this is, I think, actually
quite important.
That's not necessarily saying any of your interactions. That
appears to be saying anything to do with the policy agendas in
particular. There's no comma between officials or others. >> So,
the question then is what the [__] is Chorus' policy
agenda? >> Which we don't know. Yes. >> So, that
and it's like, well, what what exactly are you trying to become
a middleman for? Because these middleman organizations already
exist. Just real quick as well, you caught number three, right?
Some people didn't catch number three here because it was not
um obvious. So just read that as well. >> Collaborate fully
with chorus regarding all such separately arranged engagements.
Contract further agrees to participate in newsroom something.
>> I think I think this is newsroom
something booking opportunities
and then it seems to say twice a month. So, so I feel like they're
they're trying to get people using I I believe this is some kind
of software, right, that they do this through. >> And I
think they're trying to get more people using this software,
filling this software with like uh like contacts for other people.
Now, this could be totally uh like totally positive. Hey, we're
going to have you know, you come, you affiliate with us, and
then you get access to all these politicians, right? I think
this is something similar to what Pavey did. I think Pavey was
trying to use I think Roano was the big one they were pulling
people in to talk to, right? So, I think that's what they're
trying to do here. but collaborate fully with Chorus. I think
it is a little weird to say that like, okay, if you're a part
of this program, you now have to loop us in and give us contact
info for all of the people you talk to on any of these issues.
Right now, I'm guessing policy agenda. That's almost certainly
going to be I can't imagine a conversation you're going to have
with a politician that doesn't touch on some part of what like
an organization would have like this as a policy agenda. >> Well,
Dickers was like, well, is it like democracy? It's like, well,
that's a mission statement. That's the sort of like generic thing
you get out. policy agenda is usually things that tie directly
to kind of we're an org and these are the things we're promoting.
It be multiple things and I think the funding group that they're
associated with which is the
1630 fund have their >> yeah policy agendas involving climate
racial stuff and um something else. So certainly you've got those
elements. One thing that I do want to be clear cuz I can see
Xir in the chat. One thing that's worth noting about PV, and
this is how Chorus is different and therefore actually has much
less of an excuse, is that PV when it was originally founded,
if you go back to watching that when it was Voschair,
um this is long before the >> Yeah. Riverboat, Jack, Xanderhal,
Vos, these people. Yeah. Y >> they all promoted PV and
said they were sponsored. Uh and that was actually part of the
agreement. The reason that changed, and I know this because I
have an interview with Soattle,
>> um is because Twitch policy changed. So, but Chorus
has nothing like this because they're not just dealing with Twitch
creators. They're dealing with general content creators like
on Tik Tok and everything else. So, they don't have that excuse.
I can't see any reason why they would push for non-disclosure.
>> Um, I think I think that's pretty clear to me. If you
want if you want to describe them a bad motive, to me, the reason
they're going for non-disclosure is they want by by sponsoring
these smaller creators 250 250 bucks a month or something, right?
Am I sponsoring these people? I think what they want is the appearance
of like organic movement that has a lot of similar talking points
that is manufactured,
right? If you want to take it,
>> they they've tried to say, "Oh, it's about the safety
of like other creators and stuff like that." And I'm like, >> I
just don't see how that could possibly be. I think you could
easily let creators keep themselves like private in that newsroom
so their contact info can't be seen or something like I don't
know. I don't know why you would know all the other creators
in this if you're
>> Um yeah, I don't know. >> Yeah, I mean it's it's
I think someone said it's like millions of subs that um followers
that people have gained through this. So it's quite clearly like
>> Tyler Cohen said this. Yeah. That they've gained a lot.
>> Yeah. It's like >> well just getting astroturf
then >> that number only goes up, right? Like, yeah, the
collaborations could be good, but then you it's like um it's
like guys, way more money is being spent because we added like,
you know, 50 new locations, but like the same customer base is
just spread across those 50 locations. They just count as a unique
customer between each of the 50, right? Like if you have 50 locations,
they could be sub to 50 things. I don't know that you're like
necessarily generating a lot of new
anything. You're you're like spreading it around. And maybe that
lets like good creators rise to the top, but I don't think there's
like necessarily a lot of organic new views going to to stuff.
But I I don't know. That's kind of how I look at it. But like
they're saying that this is a mark of success. I I'm not totally
sure. Anyway, go. >> Yeah. I don't I don't think it is.
One thing that was interesting was the fact that it's like, well,
we want people to be like in the bubble. It's like maybe don't
criticize people who are also part of this group. And one of
the things of if your viewership's coming from this chorus group
and you're relying on that network, that's even more of a per
perverse incentive to sort of stay in line. And I actually made
the illusion to sort of the old way the Destiny and Bosch groups
worked where it's like, well, if you're in the orbit, you're
much less likely to land attacks on other people in that orbit,
which we saw with PV. This was the criticism on Connor
and Woo when the Vosch stuff happened. It's like, well, you seem
to really hate Lollcon before, but now now Vosch is involved
and you're all part of PV and then you're doing this IRL politics
like, okay, now it's now it's not worth talking about. There's
bigger fish to fry. That's obviously [__]
>> That's uh that's Conor's flexible spine at play there.
Yeah. Very interesting. >> Yeah, I did I I actually recently
had a conversation with Connor about this because I'm doing a
food shops video, so it you know, we did talk about it. Um,
but yeah, it's it's not exactly a great look. Uh, and for something
like online politics where it's so based on kind of your reputation
and credibility and authenticity,
I mean, I think these things are pretty damning. I saw one person's
video where it was like, well, you know, if you think I'm not
trustworthy now, if you don't think I'm credible, it's like,
well, you don't look very credible right now, >> dude.
It's uh, Wait, wait. So, are you talking about Connor? You talking
about somebody from chorus? >> I was talking about chorus,
right? >> I was talking about >> Oh, you're talking
about chorus. Sorry. >> But I mean, but at the same time,
but yeah, I mean ultimately stuff like this does affect credibility.
Um, and with political stuff in particular, it's going to have
a massive impact, right? Cuz it looks like, you know, if if you've
got these strong political stances where you're like this thing
bad for ethical reasons, uh, and we need to do something about
it, but also don't look over there. Yeah. That's pretty, you
know, that's pretty [__] up. This could have been
such an easy thing to deflect without going this way, too. They
could have easily just been like, "Yeah, this was an early version
of the contract. We've actually removed these provisions because
they don't line with our goals and or like our values. So, actually,
we've removed most of most of the procision provisions that you've
outlined in the article and here's the new contract we're going
with. Um, thank you for calling this out. It would be a problem,
right?" I think Brian Tyler Cohen could have just totally like
judo moved on this and been like, "You know what? These would
be really bad if we were doing them, but we're not. And and they
were actually just legal boiler plate that were in the contracts
that we've gotten rid of since. >> Yeah. Yeah. >> And
and all of this could just go away and and Taylor Loren kind
of gets a little W and he get Brian Tyler Cohen gets a massive
W and they just move forward as if cuz Yeah. They just all move
forward cuz I don't know if you've seen some of the Cope coming
out, but a lot of them say like, "Oh, we're we're totally they
come out with like these marching orders, these totally aligned
talking points. This is debunked. Taylor Loren takes dark money.
She's lied. This article like has so many falsehoods in it. Um,
we're a non-political nonpartisan group. Did you see that that
they've been saying they're a non-political nonpartisan
>> organization? Yeah. Funny enough,
>> Taylor say that same stuff. >> Well, did you see
Taylor posted the uh the original pitch deck for Chorus that
she had access to? >> So, Chorus is nonpartisan is a new
one. And I knew this because I don't know if you were ever a
Destiny viewer, but Brian Tyler Cohen jumped on Destiny's stream
after the election loss and talked about how we need to get aligned
on damn messaging, right? And this is basically the exact same
time he was going to be launching chorus, right? So here's the
pitch deck. We're 10 years behind. Who's we? We're losing the
narrative. Who's we? Conservative, progressive. Okay, maybe.
Maybe the mood. Democrats fume over weak early response to Trump.
It's a war. Do Democrats get that? What the [__]
are Democrats doing? Democrats wonder where their leaders are,
right? It's like I don't know who he thinks he's fooling. As
if he didn't talk about this all the time, how Democrats need
to get aligned on messaging. And as if chorus isn't the precise
response to that, but yeah, now they're running with I guess
uh guys, we're not like we're not involved with the Democratic
party at all. We're 0% involved with the Democratic Party. It's
like, well, why did you run a pitch deck to originally pitch
this to donors
with the exact opposite messaging? >> Yeah. I mean, like,
do they have any right-wing creators on the payroll? >> Cuz
at least PB could argue like Connor is on the was on the payroll
and he's not a Democrat, >> you know? >> Um, dude,
what a [__] show. >> She posted an article
as well. It seems like Taylor Loren posted an article that seems
to be claiming this. I was going to go I'm at some point gonna
go watch this Brian Tyler Cohen, you know, appearance on Destiny
where he talks about getting Dems in line on messaging because
I I just find it crazy that people can come out and like lie
outright and then lie outright not just about Taylor Loren's
and and the things she's done, but also lie outright about like
what the goals of their organization are. And nobody is comfortable
just saying, "Well, you're obviously lying." >> Yeah. Like
they're all incentivized to just go along with the lie, right?
in the exact way like I recognize it because I understand that
like >> when you have somebody who you rely on for viewership
and you you know have criticisms of them sometimes it's just
way easier to take somebody you don't like and criticize them
instead. That's like the way easier thing to do, right? For everybody.
Everybody's like that. >> Yeah. I don't I don't necessarily
want to crit criticize my meal ticket. You know who I'm going
to criticize? Tell Loren this stupid [__] She loves
Hassan. I hate Hassan. I'm going to go after her. Right. So,
I recognize the
>> I just I feel like it's easy for me to call it out at
this point and I feel compelled to. So, >> well, I think
that this is one of those things. So, I mean, from my perspective,
and again, if you go back to me looking at what I said during
the uh PV stuff, I mean, one of the I think one of the most interesting
conversations I had during the PV stuff was actually with Connor.
He was doing this round robin of people coming in and being like,
"Well, what about the political stuff? What about what about
this?" And, you know, he was like, "This is why you're all ineffective."
And then he got to me and I was like I don't care about the political
stuff. I care about the ecosystem impacts and incentivizing people.
I view this as lying to your audience. That's you know if if
you are happy to work with somebody and you think what they are
doing is good you should be happy putting your name on that.
Now with chorus it's a little bit difficult because chorus like
you outright cannot do that. we're not letting you apparently
seemingly that's that's the claim which is is slightly different
but at the same time it's one of these things of when you're
looking at sponsorships and on Dicker stream I said this you
know I've I've got um a friend of mine who actually does a lot
of sponsorship stuff with video games with content creators
you your your audience is your product
um you are essentially monetizing the fact that they exist and
I think the you at least owe your audience the basic respect
act
to be like, "Yeah, this is this is I'm receiving money for this.
It's having these impacts. You guys should know that." And then
you guys can make a decision. That's what transparency looks
like. And obviously, if you're being honest about that, most
people are fine. And if you want the evidence for that, it's
when Wick was sponsored by PB to do the um >> Rebellion
Pack, >> Rebellion, sorry, sponsored by Rebellion Pack
to do the panels, everyone was
>> Everyone was fine with it. No one cared. No one gave
a >> because it was out in the open. >> I Yeah, I
I would say even further from that, like people could just ask
what what would you want them to do instead? It's like be transparent,
get rid of the contract provisions that control what they say
and get rid of the contract provisions that um like just any
of the contract provisions outlined that seem kind of shifty,
right? But yeah, transparency is like one of the big things.
It's like I have very achievable goals that like very achievable
demands of like something like this. They're not even don't take
dark money. I'm like I'm not even remotely on that page. People
be like, "Dude, have you have you seen some of the defenses where
people are just like these people just don't want influencers
to make money? They just don't understand that influencers should
be allowed to make money." It's like, "No, we all get that. You
could just be transparent about it." >> Very much understand
that. Yeah. >> It's like, could you imagine if somebody
came on stream and was like, "Hey guys, you know, I've got this
new game that I've been playing and I absolutely love it. I think
you'd love it, too." Now, listen, I It's a little underground.
It's called Rage Shadow Legends. Okay, I'm just going to play
some for the next 3 hours. And hey, if you want to like join
my guild, you can. You like it would be insane if somebody was
being sponsored to do that to their audience. We'd all know that
was insane. We'd all call that out and saying, but then we get
to stuff like this. And because it's tribal, everyone's like,
"No, no, no. Okay, but it's for a good cause." Okay, we've got
to defeat Trump who might be dead anyway. I don't know. Has anyone
seen him in the last couple of days? >> Oh, no. He's out.
He's not dead. He's not dead. He's not dead. >> Oh, okay.
Well, listen. Wish
but yeah, like I I I don't like that excuse. I think it's crazy,
frankly. I think it's I think it's really mental. I I think people
are selling themselves out. Um
and they'd have an issue if the right was doing this, right?
Remember, everyone jumped on the tenants stuff. Everyone was
like, "This is crazy. I can't believe you're taking all this
money from Russia."
>> I think um
so that's Yeah, I think there are some overlaps. I think it's
tough to optically argue the tenant stuff cuz people will just
soy and go, "No, that's different. It's from a foreign adversary.
That's different. That's different. That's different." Right?
It's like, well, technically you could argue that Tim might not
have known that. I don't believe that. But you could argue that
Tim might not have known that, right? He might have thought it
was just from somebody interested in American politics thought
it was legitimate or legal. >> Yeah. He totally just thought
that somebody wanted to give him, you know, huge sums of money
for no reason.
>> Yeah. But that's that's the thing to me. I've seen a
couple of people call out like, "Oh, don't you understand this
is just like seed money for like a for like a business." And
I'm like, "No, for-profit ventures funding for-profit ventures
for a piece of the the smaller for-profit venture is like literally
just capitalism. It's literally America. It's how things have
worked forever. I understand that's the profit incentive. I get
it. When you tell me that you're just giving $8,000 to this creator
a month for six months or something because you like creators,
I'm like, "Yeah, I I'm sorry. It seems confusing. It was the
same criticism with the tenant stuff in that way, right? Where
it's like, wait, they're giving you $100,000 per episode for
a non-exclusive license so they could put one of your shows,
the YouTube videos from that on their channel. That seems weird,
right? >> Like that's more than a Yeah, that's more than
a lot of people get for an exclusive license to their content.
And it's a non-exclusive license. You can still collect revenues
on everything on on those episodes on every other
>> So, it just seems like I don't I don't get it, man.
>> Let's be honest as well. Like I think some of the I
don't know what the amounts of them we're talking about here.
With PV it was like somewhere in the region of a grand uh depending
if you're a bigger maybe you were getting like I think the highest
was 3.5. I could be wrong there because I think death turned
down any money. >> I think it was uh I don't think it was
for Wash. Um I don't know >> you're cooking by yourself.
I can hear you but you're cooking by yourself for like 45 seconds.
I'll be right back. Give me two seconds. >> Yeah. No stress.
I'm listening. So, like
I think when you're looking at the monetary incentives behind
this, it seems like a decent amount, right? If especially if
we're talking about apparently small creators who were just starting
out. I mean, 8 8 grand if this is if this was like a standard
payment. That's enough to completely like not have to worry about
any donos, any other sponsorships, any ad revenue. That's that's
an okay income like for a small that's actually a very good income
for a small creator. So that like that's that's incentive huge
not to lose that. If you're like talking about maybe like some
income for a small creator where it's like a grand a month and
you've grown, you can probably eat that loss. But 8 grand, dude,
that's the sort of thing you become dependent on real quickly.
Uh, so I I I I don't know how any of them think that's normal.
The other thing of like, well, you need influencers to make money,
you know, and everything else. Well, I'm sorry. If you've got
somebody who's got like no proven ability to like maintain or
grow their own audience,
doesn't it seem crazy to be giving them large sums of money?
Like this is the I would almost argue the definition of astrourfing
people, right? like, you know, >> it's astroturfing. Yes.
I think this is the this is basically like Kilo's I I think maybe
Kilo's strongest argument about Wick getting the amount of money
he was getting. Unfortunately, he he kind of powerbombed Wick
in his video. A couple people went after Wick, but it's like
I think Wick was getting one or 2K. And it's like that's probably
half or more of the amount he's making, right, from content creation.
And that seems like obviously he's now dependent on it. He's
like, yeah, the incentives are I just tying it back to PV again.
I think um that's a good question. >> I don't disagree
with you even though I don't necessarily have the problem with
it. I think the difference I would say the difference in the
defense I'd give to Wick is that he's somebody who you could
argue
it's quite clear from the way the recruiting was done from PV.
It was on a friend basis at least somebody who had grown a channel
and an audience
um that was in some way connected to DJ. I mean, you know, question
independently in the politics space, but yeah, it's uh
>> I'm just checking out this is uh I believe Ally is somebody
who set out as getting one of the $8,000 offers. So, I was just
looking at this. So, $650,000 followers on Tik Tok. That's pretty
big on Tik Tok, right? >> 3.5 million views on >> Trump
hasn't the Trump dying thing. 16 hours. So, this is like pretty
massive viewership on Tik Tok for a couple of these things, right?
>> Uh let me see her YouTube. What does she got? 212. So,
yeah, she's getting like reasonable views on on some of this
other stuff. >> What's her actual viewership on YouTube?
Can you bring up her YouTube channel? >> Yeah, I've got
it. I've got it up here. >> Okay, cool. Sorry, I was watching
the So, I mean, okay. Yeah, it is. But, sorry, let me make this
bigger so I can actually read some of these numbers. I mean,
sure, but her actual numbers are right. They're not great. >> She's
got two 212K subscribers.
>> Shorts. Yeah, she's a shorts creator. Yeah, cuz she's
the Tik Tok creator, right? So, obviously she just uploaded her
Tik Tok short Tik Toks onto >> Yeah, but I mean like this
kind of stuff is I I guess Okay. Okay. I guess if you're making
that argument like sure it's got some value, but this is me being
also elitist about shorts being useless content. And I mean,
Tik Tok viewership is so non-ransferable, it's actually crazy.
But I know a lot of people are trying to move over there with
things. So maybe that's a new platform, you know, though it is
slightly ironic uh given the accusations of Tik Tok and like
media messaging control control for China, but never mind. Dude,
also some of these Tik Tok views really aren't that good uh for
what you'd expect from a shorts channel with that many subscribers.
Actually, you'd expect I'd expect far higher. So like her Tik
Tok's good. >> Well, sometime I mean some of these are
like 18k,
>> 10K.
She's hitting like a million view video every video about
>> month. I don't know. But I don't I I I'm guessing that
monetization on Tik Tok is not anything. >> So you said
this so so when did she Okay, but what was she doing? When did
she sign up for Chorus? How much of an impact has Chorus had
on her? >> So Chorus has only had the incubator program
for a month. I think it was in July when it kicked off. Let me
pull up the article here. Uh, not that
dark
dark money. Okay, so incubator
should go to the top. Democrats hope. Okay, that just clicked
over by itself. Cool. Program kicked off last month and creators
were invol creators involved were told by chorus that over 90
influencers were set to take part.
So
last month, >> when I saw her video, she was like, "Oh,
and the idea is that once this is all done, once the 6 month
program is over, you'll be set up to be an independent content
creator." If you're getting these kind of views, shouldn't you
be set up to be an independent content creator already? Like,
how much money do you need to be an independent content creator?
Is this just Do I just sound really elitist? I mean, like, check
me if I am, but it's like surely if you're getting those kind
of views and you're that kind of channel, off the ad revenue
alone, you'd be bringing in
like at least at least a couple of grand a month. At least like
probably about three four at the very least would be the expectation,
I imagine.
>> I was trying to think of like Yeah. So, basically, I'm
just trying to think of like So, I think they want to get these
people on multiple platforms. I think there is something here.
there is something to like can we translate some of these Tik
Tok influencers who are big there over to YouTube. I think there's
like a feeling of that. I'm just not totally sure. Like I wonder
if this kicks off and like this stuff these four these seem to
be far more in line with Okay, you're aware of like the Midas
slop algorithm, right? >> You aware of the Midas slop algorithm?
>> You ready? You ready? Brian Tyler Cohen Cohen YouTube.
Actually, BTC is the only one I don't know does this. Okay, I
don't know if he does it. He might not. He's He might just use
his own face. Okay, BTC doesn't. But there is uh this is the
Midas slop. So, hold on. Let's go. Midas touch. Midas touch.
Okay, we go to videos. We get a lot of yellow text, a lot of
yellow arrows. Okay, we got a yellow arrow pointing at Trump's
face. We go to our buddy
absolute number one friend of the program. Okay. Pondering politics.
Everybody's a Midas slobber. Okay. Everybody, we are yellow text.
Red arrows. Okay. I like the red arrow accent. All right. I like
it. I like it. It's cool. What about our buddy Luke Beasley?
How's Luke Beasley doing? Luke Beasley. Yellow text. Not as many
arrows. Okay. Couple arrows. Not as many arrows, but yellow text.
Arrows. >> Dude, this is unreal. What? You got like should
not be interchangeable with someone else's. That's insane. What?
>> This is I am Alex thing, but for >> slopping over
here, okay, we're smite is slopping. And I think this is like
an effort to I feel like you could almost certainly tune her
like re-engagement with YouTube to or her engagement with this
program to like this. Oh, they they brought her in and this was
one of their technical trainings. Okay. How to might a slop with
a book nail. >> I think so. >> Dope box, thank you
for the five gifted. Appreciate it. Appreciate it. That's all
of them. They all talk about the same
>> Well, there's a lot of people who want to watch this.
It's so I think she's probably not going to have Well,
I don't >> Maybe she's not having quite as much success
cuz she's not quite doing the uh the Trump stuff all the time.
I think the Trump element is critical. >> That's the problem.
>> It's also possibly true. All right. There, by the way,
there are a bunch of other creators who do the same thing. Uh
I think I think Okay, I should point out for for Okay, so I should
point out yellow and red do better in thumbnails. Like bright
yellow, bright red do better in thumbnails. They do better in
the algo. I know this. You'll notice all my live stream have
like big red text like white text and red text and I use a yellow
background and stuff for things and like there is there is actually
a formula to this. It makes a difference. >> Yeah. Uh >> well,
I did this on my YouTube channel when it existed, which is over
a year ago, like almost a year and a half ago. I was already
doing this cuz uh August pointed out to me that this algorithm
pool existed and like basically said yellow arrow, yellow text,
automatic views. You'll automatically grow off this like unironically.
And it just worked the whole time. It just always
>> this is orange. This is orange. Yes. But is I just I
find it funny that like uh she's gets an arrow going in here
like out of nowhere. No arrows at all and then she's in the program
a month ago. Suddenly we got an arrow pointing at Trump. Very
interesting. >> Guys, they're going to make me in a success.
They're going to make me Dude, I I wonder if any of these people
have ever done videos or talks on dark money.
I'd be really interested to hear actually because they must have
done. It was such a talking point. Did you not Did you not watch
Alli's uh Tik Tok on You must have watched Alli's Tik Tok,
>> No, no, no, no. I was I >> No, no. I haven't seen
it. I haven't seen it. I I I'm getting I'm >> I literally
got up today, streamed about Jar, and then went to talk to Dickers
for two hours. So, I'm I'm still catching up. I read a couple
of articles, but >> I heard Jar had a new response. Hopefully
not talking about his fart fetish anymore.
No, he he leaves that out, but it is this response is actually
somehow worse. It's actually incredible. Um,
>> so this is the person of this flipp through it basically.
So I I went and saw her calendar in it, but I haven't heard the
money.
>> I I just want to watch the end of this with you. It's
about 2 minutes. Her like explanation of this is what I think
dark money is. And we're going to discuss like how accurate it
is to call this dark money. >> We're Republican and Democrat
like elections, right? like giving it to a campaign through nonprofit
organizations so that they >> she's hold on I'll back it
up in this country is like >> she tries to highlight the
difference. Okay. She tries to say giving it to a campaign. I
don't think it has to be given to a campaign. In fact, I would
argue most dark money is not given to campaigns because it's
given to super PACs which by rule cannot coordinate with campaigns.
Right. So
>> I
this the cope starts very >> mentally broken. I want to
talk a little bit about the logistics of dark money because it's
not really explained in this article. Dark money is when someone
does fundraising for the purpose of influencing elections, right?
Like giving it to a campaign through nonprofit organizations
so that they don't have to disclose the identity of the original
donor. So for example, right, we all know that Donald Trump is
helping the Cuomo campaign in New York. Now that's embarrassing
for Andrew Cuomo is the problem. So if Trump wants to >> That's
not true. >> Hold on. Pause a second. But also >> for
the purpose of influencing elections, what do you think the purpose
of political content is? At the end of the day, >> it's
a response for like by Brian Tyler Cohen's literal words, we
need to get Democrat messaging on point because our lack of ability
to to participate in the like individual independent creator
ecosystem led to us losing this election. It's literally we lost
the election cuz we didn't do this.
I can't work out whether this is a talking point that's been
given to her and she's just stupid or she's actually just come
up with it this on her own and she's [__] stupid
or she genuinely like is or she's just trying to be manipulative.
It's like one of the three. But this is this is actually
>> She's not even got we've actually not even gotten close
to the part yet, which is the best thing. Okay, cuz she keeps
going through this and she kind of like loses track of how she's
defining. It's very funny. We should >> give money to the
Cuomo campaign, but doesn't want anyone to know it was him. He
can give it to a dark money organization that again gives it
to Cuomo and nobody can trace it back to Donald Trump. I don't
like that system. And to be clear, most Americans don't like
except for the billionaires. We're pretty much all Republican
and Democrat. Like on the same page that that system is really
bad. So I was excited to join this incubator program at Chorus
for a while. It was the first of its kind on the left. I felt
like it was really important for me as a leftist to be there.
I mean, this way I can encourage people to be more critical of
Israel, encouraging them to push their representatives a little
bit harder. To me personally, I find it important to be in rooms
with people who are less critical of the system than I am because
I have the hope of like nudging these people into more strong
advocacy. And that's not always going to work, but sometimes
it does. And so when the leaders of course came to us and they
were like, "We're finally launching the program. We finally found
someone to fund this. It's the 1630 fund." I was like, "Ah, right.
Okay. Not the biggest fan of their other work. Let me think on
this." And obviously I ended up joining So to me that's pretty
obvious her basically going I know that the 1630 fund is a dark
money like liberal money group. Okay I know that right? That's
like her admitting that. I don't think she says it outright.
Let me think on this. We have to keep going. >> But it
was not without serious deliberation with my friends and my family
and my management and the the people who run chorus. And ultimately
like I want to sort of lay out for you who may be curious what
my thought process looked like. I decided that my distaste for
the fact that the 1630 fund funds some, you know, congressional
Democrat campaigns with methods that I don't like was outweighed
by the potential benefit of separate program where they have
no control over what I say where I'd be a leftist voice in a
first of its kind incubator program.
>> This is just like I can appreciate this from her cuz
she's probably like 20 years old. Okay, but this is the same
thought process that Counterpoints goes through when he justifies
him being on PV, him not actually like being a part of a conservative
movement. It's dude, Trump's bad and like I think this is the
way to go and like realistically, you know, the connections I
make and stuff. I can make a real difference later. It's just
the ends justify the means in like so many words, right? It's
very funny,
>> dude. Female 20-year-old counterpoints. Absolutely absurd.
leftist counterpoints. Amazing, dude. >> It's just like,
but so many people make this decision. Well, as long as like,
you know, I could use this money for really good. You're just
describing how every single person sacrifices their morals for
money in every story that's ever existed. Okay. It's every mafia
movie. It's every It's like a bunch of superhero movies. It's
like this story is as old as time, right? Yeah. Well, I can I
can sacrifice my morals here for a little bit more money. And
I think that's probably like going to work out long term. I think
long term it's like you're you're literally just describing how
every politician loses their way and ends up getting into like
actual
>> for 90 people to combat the manosphere. I was like,
you know what this >> oh yes listen >> I say where
>> she needs this money to combat the >> This voice
in a first of its kind incubator program for 90 people to combat
the manosphere. I was like, "You know what? This program is imperfect."
>> So, I don't know if she realizes she's off on the talking
points. You're a pro-democracy pack fighting against Trump's
destruction of democracy. Okay? You're not fighting against the
manosphere. You're out on an island with that purpose. I don't
know where that came from. Maybe this was produced before she
got the script. But the manosphere part I just thought came out
of nowhere. It was very, very interesting to me. >> But
I think that I can do good from it. And I think that the threat
of fascism is so big right now that there might need to be an
order of operations, right? We need to get rid of the fascist
threat of Donald Trump trying to take everything over and then
once me and and us buddies are in power, then we get rid of the
dark money mechanism so that >> she
just need to get into power. I just need to get in power and
then once I'm in control and all this fascism's gone, then we
can institute whatever fascism I want. This Insane.
>> I told you she hadn't gotten to the [__]
part yet >> out loud. This is
insane. What?
>> This is like every bad argument I've seen for like the
past like 3 to 6 months online, right? This is like it includes
like I hate to be, you know, I hate to be of single mind on this,
but it's it's the Destiny thing, right? Dude, there's fascism's
on the rise. We have to like have our strongest voices and he's
the strongest voice. We need to let him get away with this, okay?
It's how Connor justifies PV and canvasing for Democrats despite
him being a conservative, right? He's like, "Guys, fascism is
on the rise." And under cutting this all, okay, or under the
undercurrent of this all is is them casually not mentioning a
lot of the time the ext the financial dependence they have on
the thing they're defending, right guys? Fascism is on the rise.
So, I have to take this money. I have to take this financial
opportunity because fascism is on the rise. It's not a moral
failing. It's nothing to do with like me bending my morals at
all. It is. Fascism is on the rise. I need to take the cash.
I have to. I have to. >> Yeah. Once we have power, we can
fix
>> Go ahead. >> But like obviously like people like
this would just be thrown to the wayside. And you I I actually
think she's too dumb to realize or recognize the pattern that
this is exactly the sort of person who gets burned the minute
they're not even moderately useful anymore. But interestingly,
how does she square the circle of the fact that she's being called
out or chorus is being called out by Tyler Loren who is I think
I would describe as a fairly far extreme
>> How does she square that? I It seems like it's just
like, oh, this person's bitter. This person is like, if you want
to use Hutch's term, blackpilled leftist, right? They're blackpilled
left. So, they just want to destroy everything. I think the the
the argument you can make about Hassan and maybe Taylor Loren's,
okay, is something along the lines of like they know there's
a lot of money in just criticizing everything. They're not really
trying to get stuff done. And so I don't want to take them seriously.
I don't think they're their criticism is being done in good faith.
I think that's something I kind of agree with about Hassan in
a lot of cases. I don't know about Taylor Loren. No, they're
not.
That's just like that's just like my general take on Taylor to
be fair cuz it's like I remember Taylor from all the um from
the claims that Libs of Tik Tok made that they doxed them and
I haven't been paying attention enough to the whole thing between
her and Ethan to really pay any attention to her anymore. But
yeah, I mean my impression was that Taylor was pretty far left.
And if you're a leftist Yeah. again like you're sat here defending
and working with a dark money group or saying you hate dark money
groups. It's like well your principles are malleable then
which isn't isn't great as somebody who's trying to sell specifically
a political
>> Yeah. It's uh it's tough. Yeah. So this is the this
was the big one of the big responses. And this is actually the
response hilariously enough
that our buddy okay over at the what is it? Pod Save America.
What's this name? John Favro. John Favs.
This is the video that he uses to say, "You know what? The wired
the wired piece was incredibly dishonest." Actually, here's like
this video from Alli over here. Okay. Wired piece was wildly
dishonest. I'm truly surprised they published it. He actually
gets into a huge back and forth with Emma Vigland. This is a
tweet I haven't covered yet, I don't think, on stream. I've I've
read parts of it, just the the start. I might give this a full
read now because this is obviously this guy's massive. I are
you aware of John Favro
Pod Save America? You've probably heard of Pod Save America,
right? >> I've I've heard of Pod Save America. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Yeah. 1.3 million followers and he just comes out and
says that Tel Loren's piece is wildly dishonest and realistically
the only piece that I find dishonest about it is saying is the
by line and then a little bit of the first paragraph, right?
Other than that, it seems to be perfectly on the money like the
entire article. Uh where is my dark money thing here? So, the
buy line, an initiative aimed at boosting Democrats online, offers
influencers up to $8,000 a month to push the party line, right?
And I think what is it? The first one here
is Democratic influencers discussed whether to take advantage
of an enticing opportunity. They were being offered $8,000 per
month to take part in a secretive program aimed at bolstering
democratic messaging on the internet. I actually don't think
I think if Taylor Loren didn't write the by line, this is entire
her article. All her contributions to this article are entirely
factual. >> Is Yeah. Yeah, let's have a look at the tweet.
I'm interested. >> Oh, sorry. Somebody in my chat's asking
saying, "Hey, this is Becket, by the way, just so we're clear.
BB Poison." Okay, let's be respectful.
Or at least say ginger dickers. If you're going to say dickers,
at least say at least say the ginger part. >> I can't believe
Dickers spends enough time on your stream than that we've uh
he's he's elevated from fake Becca. This is brutal.
What is going on? >> Becca Becket has to spend more time
on the stream, I guess. I don't know what to say. It's like a
>> true fair true >> I win I win either way. I get
a British person who sounds relatively close to the other British
person. Very different interests though. So not quite the I'm
not going to say you guys are similar in basically anyway. He's
asking >> we've got we've got similarities. Both into theology
that works. >> Oh interesting.
Make dickers becket substantiate that not being principled is
bad for political ideologies because the counter is the entirety
of the US right-wing party right now. >> Uh yeah. I mean,
I don't know if I have to substantiate that. I mean, that seems
pretty obvious. I don't like this like you can't criticize one
side without criticizing the other. I mean, it's I'm leftwing.
I'm obviously not a fan of Trump or the Republican party. I I
don't know what to tell you. >> The answer there would
be the separation of like a moral bad from like a pragmatic bad,
right? Something could be morally bad and pragmatically good,
right? Like that that's just facts. like you you could have a
a decision that is well I would just say this basically like
doing the the unknown dark money funding and embracing that could
be morally bad, right? You don't know you don't know what that
money is really controlling. You don't know a lot about it. You're
just like well the other side's doing it and we have to do it.
>> Yeah. I think I I mean this seems to be something that
I've heard a few times um like when I've just glanced at this
over the last day or so where it's like well you know the rights
getting all this funding we're years behind. We saw this in like
the deck and yeah, I heard the same [__] with PV.
I was talking a bit about like uh this stuff on Dicker's stream
and obviously I looked at this when I did my masters as well
like where certain bits of funding were coming from, where the
incentives are, but yeah, the right is just massively ahead,
but the right is also better at transparency. I don't know whether
that's because the right just understands that the audience probably
isn't going to care or that's become normative as kind of a thing
of like we're working with these people because of the kind of
lingering effects of money or sponsorships or associations that
came out of kind of the 2010s uh right-wing movements online.
But yeah, they certainly get more funding and it's, you know,
no, you wouldn't be surprised to see some right-wing person turn
up and talk to a politician or have some association with a political
Uh, but I seem to remember when Chenk when had a load of things
happen with his funding, it became a big story in the left. It
does seem like the left is much more culturally against taking
money from packs and political organizations than the writers.
>> Yeah. Well, I'd say that's the leftovers of Bernie Sanders
campaigning against Citizen Citizens United and stuff like that,
right? >> Like there's a big section of the left who are
going to go along with that.
I would just say that like principally I'm not against dark money
at all because I it seems to be a part of the game. I would be
like, "Oh, we have to not do this." Like, it would be good to
not do this as soon as it could be like written out of the law.
Like, as soon as you could put some checks on Citizens United
so that you can't have like unlimited spending super PACs, right,
then I'm totally good with nobody doing it. But until that such
a time, it seems like it's the name of the game. >> Yeah.
I said this before. It's like, you know, I remember on >> I
I remember a time when um you couldn't have adverts on your YouTube
video
and a Patreon because people would accuse you of double dipping.
Like it used to be really tight with how
in uh creators actually made money and it was a bit of a taboo.
That's really changed at this point. Inuendo Studios who got
into that was that Inuendo Studios had like he was starting a
Patreon and he tried off like ads on his YouTube videos or something.
I feel like I remember that up there. >> Yeah. And it was
a big thing um in sort of like I say
anti-feminist counterculture. It's actually one of the things
that Jim started to like when he sort of like left Gamergate.
He was just like yeah this is just people getting their bag and
everyone's just you know he's selling hats now. But yeah, times
have changed and I think the thing with like sort of people getting
dark money or whatever is like, well, you're not going to be
able to change that now. So I I think I've probably moved over
the last 2 years or so where I'm like, okay, cool. It should
be transparent, but I I understand I agree with the arguments
more. I I think they're more reasonable.
but yeah, and like I see so that's so lame, take the money. Yeah,
that's very much the attitude now, but it didn't used to be.
So, thing things change. Um, and there is some truth to the fact
that if you want your creators to compete,
you do have to kind of level that playing field because that
it's not level at the moment. One thing that I did say on Dicker
stream, which I think is worth considering though, is the value
of creators comes down to what you want out of them. So, for
example, the left and the right seem to want very different thing
things out of their online creators. This is a bit broad brush,
but when we're talking about an online creator who's talking
about politics, let's say you've got an audience of 10,000 people,
well, at minimum, let's say 3,000 of those are not eligible to
vote in a US election.
Of those 7,000 left,
those people are probably going to be spread across the whole
of America in different districts.
um and will have you know what real effect on an election can
people like that have? And the answer is looking at influencers
who've tried to stand for office very very minimal. But the right
doesn't care about that because the what the right wants out
of the audience is that social media voice. They want you know
will your audience spread the talking points that are advantageous
to us. Will they be active on Twitter? Will they be active on
Facebook? and kind of can you like can they reinforce that voice?
And previously the left has never really seemed to encourage
that or thought about that. And if chorus's intention cuz you
said it's like a social media movement is to balance that out
that would actually make a lot more sense cuz that is lacking
because it realistically I think PV's shown that even canvasing
has very limited results. I don't think any of PV's candidates
[__] won. Um
it it didn't move. >> I don't think they did. I think some
of the bi-election people had success or not bi-election but
>> uh there were like oh what is it called there there
were some like uh some elections and maybe primary things where
they had some success but I >> did they primary sorry the
the actual elections I don't think they won any of those races.
Yeah,
yeah, I mean I'm happy to be shown wrong on this, but yeah, I
mean it's like how much does that move the needle? And I think
to people like Chen Yuga who again got
blown out the water when he um ran for office. So yeah, I think
the ask is different and what people want is different from the
left and the right when we've looked at this sort of previously.
But maybe that's changing. Maybe chorus is a sign. I do not believe,
you know, I agree with the one of the other statements I had.
There are probably multiple organizations doing what Chorus is
doing right now. >> I think I don't know if they'd be doing
exactly what they're doing. I do think like um I think money
is going to keep seeping into like these smaller creator ecosystems
in non-transparent ways. I think that's absolutely true, right?
I think like there's no reason to think that they wouldn't just
actually not even inform the creators, right? So, I I'm sure
there's going to be some people who are just like, I'm I'm literally
going to start a company that is just going to act like it's
a chatter and it's going to come and gift like five or 10 subs,
you know, some nights of the week, and that's going to keep that
person afloat. It's going to keep their voice afloat. It's a
voice I want amplified. It's a voice I want to keep building
content, right? >> Well, look at the uh botting scandal
on Twitch. uh the argu there's there's a potential there that
the creators involved didn't even know they were being botted
and it could have been done to make those people look more successful
for whatever you know and this is this is an accusation.
Uh, so, you know, I don't know if it's true, but it's like, okay,
well, if we've got these people in network,
then it's,
you know, it does more for us if they've got more views because
that's more sponsorship money that we're getting >> and
that's more like success that our network has. The creators may
not even know. So, in the same way, like if you've got a left-wing
organization kind of boosting you, again, it might look completely
organic and the creator may be completely uninvolved in it, which
is concerning. Certainly, I think there's a case of
people will watch somebody who look successful because people
like group think, you know, they like being part of that crowd.
If you've got a really busy chat, it's going to attract more
chatters.
>> Yeah. I think there's like a what would you call it
like a network effect that's unironically what you call it network
effect as you grow as a as a creator as you grow your audience
yeah people are I would say yeah any stream that you've got like
a massive chat just flying by all the time those look fun it
looks like something you can participate in
>> um and yeah there's there's definitely arguments that
you wouldn't even know that a lot of this stuff is happening
so that yeah it seems like we agree there I think the in network
thing is very interesting Because I think that was the biggest
falloff of the people on Twitch is I think the Faze people had
massive falloffs, right? And it's like, okay, well, seems likely
that those guys weren't botting themselves. Seems likely that
like FaZe was probably trying to make them look bigger than they
were. >> Yeah, that seems to be the evidence. uh and I
mean that's that could potentially have big
big repercussions
because you know not just from a credibility of the creator but
if you're like a sponsor who like looks for creators to sell
a product well they do that for live streamers based off your
concurrent chat that's the met that's the one of the main metrics
>> it's watch time and concurrent chat for like if you
so let's say you've got a stream of like a thousand people who
are going to watch for 8 hours. >> That is valuable to
a sponsor because that is a captive audience that you constantly
have. So if that stream turns out to not be a thousand, it turns
out to be 500,
then you have like that's potentially like a bit fraudulent potentially.
I don't know what the legality would be, but companies may see
that as you like especially if it's been done by the network.
Um, I don't know whether you could make an argument of that's
you fraudulently boosting data for to gain higher contracts because
there is a calculation.
That's the argument that uh Trainrex and Devon Nash and XQC are
pushing. Uh they're coming on kick. They're pushing it. They're
saying explicitly people are not botting even for the concurrent
viewership even though that gets you more money. What they're
botting for is they're botting to fake their way into sponsorships
because sponsorship deals are massive based on the bigger concurrent
viewership. And not only are they not only are they um like lying
to those sponsors and and not fulfilling the way they should
be, they're actually hurting the entire ecosystem because people
are looking at that like Twitch is an ecosystem and saying, "Oh,
this guy had like 30,000 concurrent and he fulfilled like 1%
of what I'd expect that to be, right? Oh, Twitch is a platform.
We can't be on that platform. Kick is a platform. we can't be
on that platform because the views are all fake,
>> And they just exit. Just money going out of the space.
Yeah. So, it's it's like honestly for how you can market that
viewership too. Like that is why people are botting. Sponsors
on kick. There are sponsors on kick that aren't uh stake. >> I've
gotten offers for sponsors on kick >> I don't think people
realize how often sponsorships come up. I've been offered sponsorship
for Copen S which uh I haven't taken for like you know gaming
products or whatever like for like things I think we >> we
got something like one of these uh mobile mobile game things
but yeah like cuz if you've got a decent concurrent people want
you know that's that's an interest you know and it's also it
doesn't you don't have to be massive but obviously for the big
big payouts
it helps. All right. Can we have a look at this tweet? I'm interested
to see what he actually said. >> The John Favro tweet.
Yeah. >> So, he followed it up and
where' I put him? There he is.
So, he tweeted out, "EBA says, "Wait, Wyard's like reputable,
right? Why wouldn't you trust them?" He responded this morning.
See her. Wired is absolutely has earned that reputation. The
reputation that they have done excellent reporting, right? Reputation
as a thorough, diligent publication. I admire and rely on their
reporting. Also glad they added some clarifications. They they
they are clarifications, but they're additive. There are there
is no retraction. There is no um there's no correction. There's
no retraction on the article as of now, which just seems odd
to me given that a bunch of people are advertising that it's
debunked. I think the video above from a progressive creator
who's being quite critical of Israel and the Democratic party
does an excellent job conveying why this piece why the piece
is dishonest. So, I'd encourage folks to watch it. This is a
six-month training program for progressive creators that pays
them 8K a month uh an $8,000 uh dollar a month stipend while
they learn best practices and get to connect with other influencers,
activists, and politicians. They're not paid to push the party
line, as the headline suggests, and no one, including the reporting
in the piece, has proved otherwise.
Calling on Chuck Schumer to step down is not pushing the party
line. These creators can clearly express whatever opinions they'd
like about politics in the Democratic Party. They can interview
whoever they'd like. They can tell people they're a part of the
program. The contract asks them to give Chorus a heads up on
these things first. Seems like pretty standard legal stuff. Wait,
why would they need to Does it say you can ask and then it says
you need express consent? So, he's just not reading. He's just,
right, you need I I believe at least one of these things you
need express consent. I is that to use chorus funds to on a politician,
right? So, he's just not reading in that case. They can tell
people they're part of the program. So this is not was not a
part of the contract and they had to give a clarification on
this and they said this is how you can tell people you are part
of the program. They gave explicit talking points for how you
can discuss that. Right. They can interview whoever they like.
They have to >> attack the article apparently according
to the very similar tweets. >> You'd think so. They can
interview whoever they'd like but not they cannot hoard that
information. They cannot hoard that contact to themselves. They
have to share that. They have to collaborate with the actual
platform.
So, oh, you know, I'm just realizing collaborate might mean that
you fill out something to show you're collaborating with that
politician. You might add them as like a contact to the chorus
deck in the back end to like the chorus. >> Yeah, that
seemed to be the implication as I was reading it. It's like it
gets them into the network and then the next time another creator's
like, "Oh, this politician's like, well, they're in the network."
And then you get to grow that internal bubble.
>> Favs is just right here. No, he's not. He's objectively
not correct. He is objectively not correct. This is
There is no correction on this part of the article. They can
tell people they're a part of the program. This is misleading.
They tell you how you can say it. The contract asks them to give
course a heads up on these things first. For some of these things,
it says they need express written consent from Chorus to do it.
That is not them having total control. That is a lie. You are
lying. Why is he lying? I don't know. I don't know why he'd be
incentivized to to mislead people with this, but it's just not
true. It's explicitly not true. That means they can. Okay, you
can uh you can talk about me in my chat as long as you have my
express consent. Now, I'm never going to give that consent to
you. Can you talk in my chat? >> If you've banned him before
he can respond, that's even funnier. But >> I haven't.
But it's like it's it's so stupid. I don't know. Like I don't
know how people can show up places and just be this embarrassing
like all of the time. How can you say you're allowed to say something
if you need the express written consent of somebody to do it
first? It seems wrong. >> Women can leave my basement as
long as they get my express consent. It's not that hard. >> I
I just don't get it. Anyway, by the way, still saying as long
as you disclose and as long as they get rid of a couple of these
contract provisions, I have no problem with what Chorus is doing.
But this is just incorrect. And the article makes claims about
what the contracts state. The article is entirely accurate about
what it says the contract states. I've not seen anything disproving
any of the claims the article has made about the contracts offered
by >> Didn't the article seem to imply, you know, I've
I've, you know, isn't there implication?
Sorry. >> Yeah. Hasn't there been an implication that some
of the people involved with Chorus have actually come out to
talk about this like two journalists as well who have been covering
this? because they're saying, well, we spoke to these people
and there was this trepidation over this. They had issues over
this part of the contract.
>> Sure. It seems like they talked to some of the people
who were offered the contracts, but I would also say that um
there's been people who have come out and on the other side and
spoken positively of them as well. But yeah, I think I think
they said they didn't want to. I have no idea what that means.
They're also like probably lefty adjacent content creators as
well. So sometimes when I hear like what the creators themselves
say, I'm like, "Okay, I have to filter this through the lens
of like the fragile leftist content creator who's always complaining
about >> Yeah. Yeah, that makes sense. >> I'm going
to cover food shops and Destiny talking a little bit later about
some stuff and I'm going to have this on screen the whole time.
What do you think? As food shops defends um Lollcon to Destiny
says it's like GTA.
If you want you want to argue lollycon is bad. If you want to
argue lollycon is bad, then you should argue that GTA causes
No way. She actually discussed I don't believe you. No [__]
way
with Destiny. >> Hi, I'm Connor and I approve this message.
Let's Conor. >> She knows I'm making a video. She knows.
I don't I don't understand. Like I was watching some of this
last night actually cuz I was just through and I was just like,
"Bro, why are you saying this?
This is a choice. I I feel like I'm being OPP. Maybe maybe she
just wants me to talk about the uh lolly stuff. Maybe that's
the intention. There's so much more with food shops to talk about.
>> Honestly, to me, I feel like Destiny was unaware that
Connor had gone out on an island kind of and had been so against
Loi and so against food shops in general and he just realized
he had the opportunity to humiliate him. He just realized that
like, oh, I'm going to go hang out with this food chops person
a bunch. I'm going to go on this stream. I'm going to raid them.
I'm going to raid them while they're reacting to the Drew Pavloo
debate with my teenage son. Yes, I'm going to re I'm going to
raid this who is reacting to my son's content online while criticizing
people for reacting to my son's content online. And again, I
really wish I'd had I really wish I'd had this back then, but
I'm looking forward to Okay, it's Connor.
>> Like the the >> Valor Media Network seal of approval.
The the reason obviously that Destiny is raiding into food shops
is because he thinks that boosting food shops will annoy Quean.
Um that's that's the obvious reason. I can't I can't actually
think of another one. >> It's literally that they like
a log all of my content. I'm pretty sure. >> Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. And and yourself. And yourself. Obviously. I was trying
to be nice about it. But um
dude, that's that's awesome. I can't believe they had a conversation
about lollycon. That's hilarious. While Destiny is in the midst
of like accusations of of possessing
>> I believe that's in the same context is like she's defending
him for possessing in some way or saying there's like no proof
of this. I don't know. It's very
>> one I I did see one clip from that that someone sent
me uh this morning which is like food shops is going I've not
actually seen this docs. I've not seen it. I I've not seen any
of theirs. And then she asked Destiny, "Hey, did you dox this
person?" He was like, "I don't know. Maybe. I don't remember."
I was like, "Brutal." Absolutely [__] brutal. Incredible.
>> Well, they argue that that it's like totally fine to
dox these people, try to dox me, to try to dox like Queen, to
try to dox anybody. They argue that this is all legitimate to
try. >> Yeah. Yeah. is like like ironically for all the
claims that it's like Chudlo Logic's community is prodoxy, the
only person the only two people I've heard make proxying arguments
are Destiny and food shops. What? Insane. Absolutely insane.
I just >> I don't understand it. I don't get it. But um
>> genuinely very funny. >> Yeah. He also Oh, did
you see the um the Doobie thing? Did you see Destiny, you know,
go on Wix thing and is he signing off? You see any of that [__]
No, no. I I tuned in a little bit and then I just tuned out.
I was like, they're just talking about politics. I don't really
>> As he's signing off, he references a debate Doobie had
with like one of his the guy who went to his Pixie trial thing
in Florida. There's like >> Oh, yeah. Yeah. I've heard
about this guy. Yeah. Yeah. >> And um and then Baby Peach
is there. They're both on stream. I'm not going to show him right
now. Well, I maybe I could, but um he basically says some stuff
and then he's like, "Yeah, Duby's like disgusting. He's like
trying to
basically insist he's like doing disgusting things in the background.
He's like running ops on me and he's like, "Yeah, so good on
you, Wick, for pushing back against somebody who runs an insurance
company, by the way." And who's like saying disgusting things
in the background. It's like, wait, why did you drop that piece
of information in there? Did you propose nothing?
>> Apparently. Yeah, apparently. >> The why? Like
>> I could I'll just I'll cuz he thinks Dubbie is like
um because Dubie was a Pisco viewer. He's like trying to run
this idea that Dubbie is a part of a Cabal with me and Quimman
and he's like trying to turn people against destiny,
>> Okay. Well, I mean this is the first I've heard of Doobie
existing
in about a year and a half. Like have you have you spoken to
Doobie then? >> Not on stream just a little bit. >> That
was bizarre. Like yeah, Doobie's always been like a free agent
just doing his own [__] >> Yeah. And wasn't
really against Destiny basically believes that if you're like
frustrated by his conduct at all, if you're like against his
conduct, you think he's a bad person, then you're like an op.
You're like uh somebody who's like totally trying to build a
conspiracy against him in some way.
>> Yeah, dude. Is I I said this um I said this to Connor.
Um, so I mean it's recorded and on the record, but I was like,
I don't think I've ever seen Destiny like this. I think this
is the most brain broken I've ever seen him. And it is weird
actually. Like you'd think that someone's been doing this for
so long would just not be making these obvious optical mistakes.
Though then again, what's left of UGG is so like committed to
him. Then they're not going to turn now. He's almost
safe.
Um
I like what like what could he actually do that DG's
>> nothing they Dude did you hold on the uh do I have the
Mantis tweet? Come on. Where is this tweet? It's got to be somewhere.
There's a Mantis tweet where she basically says like not even
child can make Destiny not cool to me. Um it's like I swear to
God that is like the actual context is the actual like effect
of the message.
Oh come on. It's got to be here somewhere. Please. I can't find
it. Somebody find the tweet for me. Is it gone? I'll find it.
I'll find it really quickly. Give me a second. >> Yeah.
Yeah. Take your time. I want to see it. I've Listen, I'm [__]
I'm all in. I What I love about uh this kind of drama, especially
with like cuz I've always um I've always been more interested
in Destiny's orbiters than Destiny himself. and more interested
in sort of like drama between these little
um of which I was one, you know, not not in Destiny's orbit,
but in the political
um than Destiny himself. So, hearing all this happen and how
it's unfolding is just absolutely incredible. >> There
it is. It's on screen. Sorry, I also have dinner. Um >> No,
you're good. How mad will the haters be when this drama blows
over and people still prefer Destiny to them? Not even caning
do it, dude. Guys, that's cool. Listen, we'll we'll site Listen,
even if Destiny is a like it's worth it. It's worth it to see
Queen unhappy. These people are brain broken. It's insane. >> The
best the best part of this, okay, to me
is that at the start, Destiny was like confident, okay? He was
like very confident he's like going to get through this. And
he told people, "Do not make like weird arguments about consent
and with me, okay? Don't don't like defend me in a way that makes
me look bad. Don't do that. That's bad optics. And now he's like
so hungry for for defense in any way that he's like straight
up hanging out with like a a vowed avowed lollycon, okay, on
stream. And like comments like this, he's got like no issue with
them at all. Like he he's just like any defense any defense at
all, I'll take it. Please, please do not hold back on. Anybody
wants to support me, I'm down with whatever you say. >> I
mean, I should say as well like cuz I I I don't know this like
stuff with the Destiny thing, it spiral. I think it's made worse
by just how insane the spiral has gotten because I don't think
I I'm sure there are some people out there are crazy. I I don't
think there's a claim here that Destiny is actually a or anything
like that. I think it's just that Destiny's dumb and this seems
incredibly negligent.
Um cuz like my argument with the kind of images involving roads
is very simple. It's like, well, the minute you think this person
might be underage,
should you not I mean, you've got lawyers and things, should
you not find that out and be sure and then make sure that you're
protected? It just seems incredibly reckless. You know, >> I
uh I would say that like by the dictionary definition, like when
I go into a debate and say I'm taking the affirmative on like
Destiny's been an obvious for a long time, no, I wouldn't do
that. But I also think that when you knowingly possess child,
somebody might call you a colloquially. And I don't really think
you have a lot of room to there's not a ton of nuance there.
There's a little bit. Okay. But the colloquial use of the term
just like having sex with minors or having attraction to minors,
right? I I don't think there's I don't think there's a lot of
daylight there between what he did and and that. But I'd say
the dictionary definition, the primary attraction to prepubes
and kids, I don't think that's there. Like Ethan went Ethan went
insane. Ethan went insane with his his uh attempted >> hit.
It was pretty It was a pretty It was pretty extreme, I think.
Um like
Sorry. Why Becket got an avatar that's playing with toys? That's
a bad look. Right now, >> we don't ask questions about
Becket's community or why they all follow food shops on Twitter,
okay? We don't we don't ask questions about that. Listen, it's
the art creator community, okay? It's it is what it is, >> right?
Some of the artwork of me is absolutely [__] insane.
Okay,
let's not pretend otherwise. But dude, um >> but yeah,
I think it's one of these where I I mean I'm very careful about
the word. Uh I think I I don't think I even called food shops.
Um I'm amazingly careful about that word cuz I I think
>> really serious and you shouldn't like no one should
overuse it. But at the same time, it's like,
>> yeah, you're you're in a space where even if you're
not worried about legality, even if Destiny's like, I don't think
I'm going to go to prison for this. And I'll be honest with you,
from I I did have a couple of cuz I know some people in Law Tube
who gave me some takes and they were like, yeah, there's look
if beyond statute to limitations. It's very unlikely he'd get
convicted with anything with this. There's so many other things.
It's probably not going to prison. That was their opinion. Wait,
how much how much have you done looking into this? >> I
guess a fair amount. Um,
like cuz I was interested,
but um again, this wasn't like mainstream takes. This was uh
I actually went and tried to talk to some people and like get
an opinion. But yeah, I I think generally speaking, it seems
unlikely that he's going to prison over it. Um, >> how
do you get off on statute of limitations? Because I had potentially
criminal on. He didn't mention statute of limitations for this
at all and he seemed pretty aware that it was perceived in like
2022 2023 or sorry
>> Um I think that um
I think the argument was basically
that it would be received so long a like a a decent Wait, would
it be 2023? I suppose it would be 2033. Yeah,
>> 22.
Um
so
I I think there's something to do with the way it was received.
I'd have to go back and check the messages. But yeah, they they
weren't convinced that he'd get done for this. And on the other
side, it's to do with the fact that he seems to have taken even
if it's not like he could have done more. He did ask for identification.
He had no reason to believe she was underage. She was already
producing on Twitter apparently.
Um
so yeah, it's it's stuff like that. So they're not they like
the people I spoke to weren't convinced that he'd go to prison
again. Like that's just a person's opinion, right? And lawyers
are often wrong. >> Just the idea that it would be statute
of limitations, I thought was a little bit interesting to be
honest. >> Yeah. I mean, I'm not a lawyer, so generally
with legal opinions, I go to other people. They could be wrong.
They could be wrong or it could be a specific state or it could
be anything like that. I've got no idea. The other thing is I
don't know what like that looks like from space. I I think the
main thing is like, well, you know, even beyond the prison stuff,
he's like, you'd have to be pretty dumb to not know how optically
damaging any of this is. Why wouldn't you protect yourself from
that? Oh, >> yeah. I mean, oh, sorry. I'm just uh I'm laughing
at >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. >> Yeah. I'm laughing at
this. Um, mostly laughing at this cuz I wanted to go laugh at
this.
>> I'll pay you as much as course paid me. though. I'm
surpris Yeah. Uh that's pretty funny. Um yeah, can I see this?
>> I think this is going to be a lot of people responding
to uh a lot of people responding to Destiny just going to respond
like this now. This is another reason. Okay. It's like a huge
debuff to somebody having these allegations, right? When they
can just respond to you like this on the internet. I feel like
it's I don't know. It's kind of rough. So, you want to >> Yeah.
Can you imagine if he goes on like Pierce Morgan and someone
brings this >> Well, I Yeah. I don't even know. I don't
know why they wouldn't to be honest with >> Bro, that would
hurt. >> Most people listen not watch. Right. So, hold
on one second. Wick TV invites on the Vanguard to his stream
to do like a panel on the chorus stuff. Okay. I'm doing a show
on chorus later this week. Perhaps at Vanguard Pod would like
to come on and articulate how precisely it makes Pac-Man look
bad. Explain it to us plebs. So, Vanguard tweeted basically about
the David Pacman response. This is some mosh calling it fake
news because it makes you look bad. Very Trumpian, right? Okay.
Oh, I want to I want to ask Pudge publicly, but he won't he won't
answer for the Brett video. No, I didn't go over the Brett video.
That's a Brett Brook Cooper video that's mostly about Destiny's
son, who I've said I'm not covering. Why the [__]
would I cover that? Jesus Christ. >> What the made a video
about Destiny's >> Uh, yeah, >> dude.
Go on. >> Yeah. Um,
so they say, so Vanguard says, "Well, we'll do your p panel,
but for $8,000. That's the going rate in your world." Wick responds,
"I'll pay you as much as Chorus has paid me. How's that?" Oh,
Wick is not a part of Chorus.
Desi responds to that $8,000 tweet. It says, "Avoiding critical
conversations should call your credibility into question way
more than having any sources of funding." Uh-huh.
Isn't this the guy who refused to cover the Ethan part of the
video that went into Rose getting doxed by him? And then he avoided
that entirely and said he wouldn't go on the H3 pod to answer
any questions that might have like a personal element to them
despite making content out of those things for weeks now, months
now. He continues, "When cowards like at Vanguard Pod and other
socialist, communist, manga types avoid critical conversations
because they know nothing they can uh they say can stand up to
scrutiny, they will only be able to laugh it off and make jokes
about it, but pay attention to it. It's true." Vanguard Pod responds
to Destiny, "Fuck off, loser. We're too old for you." Wow. They're
like not kids, so Destiny's not really interested in them. Get
it? Get it? I hope you guys all get it. >> That's his life
now, isn't it? >> That is his life now.
I I I truly believe that like uh there's some cosmic force in
the universe that looked at like his beard and and his overall
physio and we're just like we have to give people a way to call
you a
we're not going to make you touch kids but we have to give people
a way to credibly call you a without being like just totally
written off and and they found it. Okay, they found it. Uh guys,
we have about 48 minutes left on the stream. We are
seven subs away from another two hours two more hours of content.
Probably got we got a lot of stuff to cover tonight. So if you
want to go ahead and donate, all right, you can donate on you
can donate on kick. You can you can sub. You can give subs. You
can donate through either of the donate links. Okay. Streamlabs
kickbot. Go ahead. You guys know how. All right. Add some more
time to the stream. Appreciate you all. >> Okay. Can you
show me this Destiny leaving Wix panel thing? >> I'm Did
I not Did I not play it? Jesus. >> Dude, it's my fault.
It's my fault. I like tangents. Yeah. God. Yeah, >> congratulate
you for that. Even when there are creepy weirdo in the
>> Hold on. I'll back it. I'll back it up to where you
can set it up. >> Um, it was really >> Oh, hold on.
Gifted sub. Thank you very much, Puffshake. >> Crazy. I
think Duby was getting smashed
by Peach and Zip Zip. Did you see that where he got absolutely
>> Yeah, it was probably one of the worst performs I've
ever seen of any person in my entire life. I actually I'm not
sure. Do you know if Duby's like special needs >> if you
want to debate Dubbie, I can set it up?
>> Uh, no. Cuz I know that he's really upset with you for
platforming me and he thinks that that's like a really bad thing
and he tries to do a whole bunch of weird creepy like, you know,
stuff in the background to imp. But you know what, Wick? Good
on you for standing on principal. I think >> wouldn't want
to elaborate on any of that weird creepiness in the background.
>> You're a good guy. I congratulate you for that. even
when there are creepy weirdo in the background who own insurance
companies and [__] that do kind of weird stuff to
try to pressure people to do stuff. I think it's really weird
and creepy. So, good for you, Wick. Okay, I love you. Um, I'm
going to go to sleep cuz I've got
bro. Wigace,
I know. I know he's